Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Volkert.
Linus, zähl doch mal bitte runter von hundert in siebener Schritten.
Äh das geht doch gar nicht auf. Also einhundertdreiundneunzig sechsundachtzig, neunundsiebzig, zweiundsiebzig, fünfundsechzig, achtundfünfzig, einundfünfzig, vierundvierzig, siebenunddreißig drei ist äh dreiundzwanzig natürlich, sechzehn neun zwei und,
minus sieben? Nee, minus zwei?
Fünf. Die fünf. Fast. Fast hätte ich so gut.
Fast, fast hätte ich so gut gemacht wie Donald Trump.
Logbuch Netzpolitik mit einem Spezial.
Und einem Tim Ersatz. Wir wollen heute eine Monothematische Sendung machen über, wie ich finde, die,
Stadt der Welt, die schönste Stadt der Welt, die reizvollste Stadt der Welt und mein Gast heute hat in dieser.
Statt zehn Jahre gelebt.
Und wir wollen ein bisschen über äh eigentlich glaube ich über diese diesen besonderen Status dieser Stadt sprechen.
Und natürlich dann bei dem Hongkong Security-Lar.
Münden und das ein bisschen einordnen und wir müssen, glaube ich, einen ähm,
Ja, ein kleinen Disclaimer dazu geben, du bist Expat, du hast dort gewohnt, zehn Jahre lang, aber du bist kein Jurist und kein kein Experte für dieses Land.
Genau, also ich bin weder weder äh politisch noch äh juristisch ausgebildet. Ähm und habe auch in Hongkong äh nicht wirklich Chinesisch sprechen oder lesen oder schreiben gelernt. Insofern ist das alles eine sehr Expat-Auswander-geprägte
Bubble Perspektive, die ich dir hier anbieten kann, nur.
Ja, aber die äh ich denke, die ist ja, dass das Wichtige, was was so eine Erfahrung auch irgendwie ein bisschen mehr mit Leben füllt, weil auf Papier kann ja viel stehen. Und
Deswegen, also wir haben uns vorgenommen, wir sprechen äh kurz über die Geschichte, wie Hongkong überhaupt an diesen Sonderstatus gekommen ist, sprechen dann bisschen über die Stadt, was die eben so,
besonders macht, dann kommt die persönliche Sicht. Wir reden dann über den Einfluss, den China auf Hongkong
hat und jetzt inzwischen ausbaut, kommen über die Ambreader Revolution dann zuletzt zum Security Law und wollen noch so ein bisschen.
Ausblicken, wie es äh sich denn droht oder äh anschickt, weiterzuentwickeln.
Genau. Ja. Ist auch alles grad äh ja äh in der Entwicklung befindlich. Ähm aber wir können erstmal anfangen die äh das alles äh geschichtlich einzuordnen.
Also ich ich kann mich das äh ich kann mich als erstes so meine erste Erinnerung an politisches in Hongkong ist tatsächlich ähm neunzehnhundertvierundneunzig nee neunzehnhundertsiebenundneunzig.
Hongkong wird von den Briten in die Freiheit entlassen.
Genau und Queen Elizabeth fährt mit ihrem mit ihrer eigenen Yacht wieder nach Hause. Von Hong Kong, das war, das war dann der Taty Medienbilder.
Ich habe damals als als äh Vierzehnjähriger gedacht oder Dreizehnjährige so, ja äh wieso Hongkong, hä? Das ist doch eh das ist doch China oder nicht, ne? Und der das war mir irgendwie alles so ein bisschen komisch und,
Wieso hatten die Briten überhaupt Hongkong? Oder oder was ist Hongkong? Hongkong ist eine Hafenstadt in China.
Hongkong sein Hafenstadt in Südchina in äh Kanton China um genau zu sein. Danach ähm.
Wurde halt acht in den äh Empfang neunzehnten Jahrhundert, achtzehnhundertzweiundvierzig von Großbritannien als Grundkolonie etabliert. Ähm halt als Hafen genutzt ähm,
Da muss man dann Geschichtsexperten fragen, wie das alles mit der äh chinesischen, größeren äh chinesischen
Geschichte zu tun hat und in Boxeraufständen und so weiter, ähm die Opi und Kriege haben damit auch viel zu tun. Das habe ich alles jetzt nicht vorbereitet. Ähm aber prinzipiell achtzehnhundertzweiundvierzig von den Briten als eine der mehreren Grundkolonien
äh etabliert.
Ähm man muss dazu sagen, Hongkong, das müssen wir auch gleich direkt auf die auf die ähm geographischen Besonderheiten so ein bisschen eingehen. Hongkong ist prinzipiell nur so ein Felsen,
kurz vor der chinesischen Festland, vor dem chinesischen Festland, beziehungsweise der kommt auch immer näher an das Festland ran, weil sie den Hafen immer immer kleiner machen. Die Stadt wächst sich so gießen. Ähm äh zueinander. Ähm aber ursprünglich war das wirklich nur Hongkong Island
dieser Felsen, ähm der von von Großbritannien als Hafen genutzt wurde, auf der Südseite Ebedien äh gibt's einen Hafen, der auch nach wie vor äh recht wichtig ist,
Die andere Seite, auf dem, auf dem stesischen Festland war damals noch nicht äh Teil der Sache. Das wurde dann aber zwanzig, dreißig Jahre später,
achtzehnhundertsechzig wurde das dann ebenfalls in die Kronkolonie aufgenommen.
Kaukau.
Genau die Halbinsel Golun, da ist dann wirklich auch nur so ein Zipfel.
Auf der, auf der anderen Seite von dem Hafen ist, der, wie gesagt, damals doch ein bisschen weiter, bisschen größer, bisschen breiter war, der Hafen. Aber das war dann zwanzig Jahre später, haben sie dann halt die Briten das erste Mal äh quasi dann die Kollegen auf das Festland erweitert.
Okay, das äh also das war zum Beispiel für mich jetzt mal ein neuer, weil also genau, es gibt Hongkong Island, das ist das, was man immer auf den Bildern sieht, ne, mit den da sind die Hochhäuser sind überall. Okay, aber da sind die die Beleucht.
Hochhäuser sind überall, aber das sieht die die ähm die ist sehr charakteristische ähm äh Skyline, die man kennt.
Ja, äh die,
HSBC und so weiter und äh das ist quasi so das äh ja, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, Mitte, weil wir uns gerade in Berlin befinden und äh Berlin Mitte ist wirklich
nicht vergleichbar mit mit Hongkong Island, dann gibt es nördlich, fängt an und darüber dann schon.
Und das ist halt das andere, ne? Also was das wollte, wollte ich jetzt weitermachen. Ähm selber ist halt so eine Halbinsel.
Ähm die war dann äh Teil der Kronkolonie und das halt auch wirklich, wo ich verstanden habe, Grundkolonie im Sinne von wir fahren da einfach,
macht hin und das gehört dann halt uns wahrscheinlich unter Einsatz von Gewalt, so wie ich das verstanden habe. Ähm,
dann allerdings gibt's also keine richtige Grenze, da gibt's dann so eine so eine kleine Bergkette oder so.
Lions Rock, der das so ein bisschen abgrenzt, ähm aber dahinter gibt's dann äh was New Territories genannt wird, weil die dann nämlich erst äh Ende des neunzehnhundert, achtzehnhundertachtundneunzig von China
von der ähm chinesischen Kreis.
Damals ähm geleast wurden. Also da das war dann ein ähm ein Vertrag zwischen der englischen Krone und der,
chinesischen Krone, also dem chinesischen Kaiserreich, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, äh wo dann genau für einhundert Jahre nämlich ähm diese Bereiche in den New Territorys äh vermietet wurden,
mit einem Ablaufdatum von neunzehnhundertsiebenundneunzig. Das kling, also neunundneunzig Jahre, so lange kann man ähm Immobilienverträge auch anscheinend maximal machen. Ähm,
Ging dann wirklich von achtzehnhundertachtundneunzig bis äh neunzehnhundertsiebenundneunzig ist das halt ausgelaufen.
Ach herrje, okay.
Deswegen musste man das auch so ein bisschen erklären, weil das äh dann ja wirklich neunzehnhundertsiebenundneunzig dann halt auch die die Neuzeit für Hongkong,
eigentlich erst anfängt, also von achtzehnhundertachtundneunzig bis äh neunzehnhundertsiebenundneunzig bis die Westwing Elizabeth mit ihrem Schiff da weggefahren ist, war das dann halt auch einfach Grundkolonie,
mit entsprechend halt im britischen Gesetz und britischen, spezifischen.
Und das ging dann da bis also diese Grenze, die also dann oben über den New Territoys kommt ja dann Shensin.
Das ist dann Direktmailentscheider, also die Volksrepublik Schiene in Shenzhen.
Eine Grenze zu China beziehungsweise ist ja auch eine das heißt so ein richtiges äh China wie so ein braucht man da auch nicht um da reinzukommen. Ich hatte.
Da gibt's auch kleine, kurz, kurzfristige vierundzwanzig Stunden Wiesn und so, je nach je nach deinem Reisepass, aber ja.
Und es gibt dann noch weitere Inseln, die jetzt Hongkong Island umgeben, insbesondere Lama Island und die, wie heißt die Insel, wo der Flughafen drauf ist?
Island.
Landau. Genau.
Und dann noch zwei, drei andere schöne Inseln. Ähm das ist alles auch wirklich alles sehr sehr malerisch da, äh nicht unerwähnt sollte man lassen, dass dann auf der anderen Seite, also Hongkong selber ähm ist an der
des äh des Perlenflusses, ähm der der Mindet äh
neben Hongkong auf der anderen Seite von dem äh Fluss, von der Flussmündung ist dann Macau, die ein exportugiesische Kolonie, die so ungefähr dieselbe Geschichte hat, auch der ungefähr den selben Status hat, wie Hongkong im Augenblick
aber deutlich weniger Einwohner und eigentlich nur Casinos, sondern insofern äh.
Genau, das ist so das das das.
Ganz dieselbe Rolle spielt.
Las Vegas von Asien oder.
Ziemlich also was Glücksspiel angeht auf jeden Fall.
Ja ich bin, man konnte da rüber fahren, habe ich aber nicht gemacht. Ich ich hatte nicht so viel Geld.
Jetzt mal rübergefahren dann, äh.
Äh dann wäre das viel mehr geworden wahrscheinlich, ne. Ähm die jetzt, also was wir darüber da dazu aufhält, also das Klima ist enorm also ja für einen Europäer eigentlich ein bisschen zu warm, aber sehr angenehm. Also ich mag's ja lieber warm als kalt.
Warm und hohe Luftfeuchtigkeit ist halt in den Tropen, ne?
Enorm, also sehr schön tropisch, ähm wie also mir kam, ehrlich gesagt, Hongkong Island auch relativ hoch vor, wenn man da hoch zu dem zu dem zu dem höchsten Punkt fährt. Äh zum ganz höchsten kommt man ja nicht, aber zu dieser Aussichtsplattform, wo man über die Stadt schaut.
Sind so ein paar hundert Meter sind das schon, ja.
Und dann kann man da äh kann man da runterblicken. Ähm.
Insgesamt, glaube ich, ja sehr also sehr enorm dicht besiedelt. Land ist unglaublich teuer, weshalb die Häuser so hoch gebaut werden, ne?
Also,
Meine Zuverständnisse nach, das am dichtesten besiedelte, gebietete Erde, also in selber im Moncock-Distrikt, wurden die meisten Menschen pro Quadratmeter halt dann auf achtzig Stockwerken, aber halt trotzdem noch auf sehr kleinem Raum und man hat wirklich nicht so viel,
also.
Und in kleinen Wohnungen.
Toilette gehen, ohne wenn du den Arm ausstreckst, dann direkt die Wand zu berühren, das ist schon alles sehr.
Zwar die Wohnzimmerwand.
Ist alles zu eng.
Ähm okay und jetzt neunzehnten siebenundneunzig endete das mit dem Mietvertrag für die New Territeries.
Der Mietvertrag ist neunzehnhundertsiebenundneunzig ausgelaufen. Ähm vorher haben sich bereits dann, also das war dann natürlich auch nicht mehr die Krone Englands, sondern halt die also,
Ist auch kein Experte für die englische Geschichte, Geschichte, aber ähm äh zumindest hat sich Großbritannien dann mit der Volksrepublik China neunzehnhundertvierundachtzig ähm,
verhandelt. Ähm da gab's natürlich die Option, ob jetzt einfach nur die zurückgegeben werden und der Rest dann einfach nach wie vor Kolonie bleibt oder unabhängig wird oder was. Ähm hat allerdings ähm,
Aufgrund der dichten Besiedlung ähm ist das Problem, dass Hongkong Island selber so ganz ohne Unterstützung von dem Land,
das im Gegenüber liegt nicht wirklich zu halten ist, also im Sinne von Wasserspeicher, Kraftwerke, äh Akrikultur. Ähm das gibt's halt einfach auf der Insel nicht. Das heißt, als Autonome,
Selbstständige oder irgendwie von England irgendwie unterhaltene Region hätte das nicht funktioniert. Insofern haben sich dann äh Großbritannien und China darauf geeinigt,
sind Gesamte. Ex-Kronenkolonie eben nicht mehr wie die geliest wurden, sondern die gesamte Grundkolonie. Dann an China zurückgegeben wird,
ähm und haben sich darauf dann, das nennt sich dann äh der von neunzehnhundertvierundachtzig, haben sich da drauf geeinigt, äh dass das Ganze als ein Land.
Nämlich Volksrepublik China, aber als zwei Systeme, nämlich zum einen die kommunistische äh,
Führung, also das kommunistische System unter dem der Volksrepublik Chile existiert, dann aber ein demokratisches System unter dem Hongkong existiert, dass das soweit äh so weitergeführt werden soll. Also dieses.
War dann in der ist in dieser dieser Joint Deklavation, dieser gemeinsamen Erklärung festgehalten worden. Ursprünglich war der Plan, dass dann auch,
schlussendlich der der äh das Staatsoberhaupt eines Schiefexcutive Officer von Hong Kong demokratisch äh mit allgemeiner Wahlberechtigung gewählt werden sollte, das steht da in dem Papier drin.
Mhm und das findet also diese Wahlen finden ja auch statt,
Unter interessanten Einschränkungen von des des passiven Wahlrechts quasi, ne, also wer da gewählt werden darf, da reden redet dann China nochmal ein bisschen mit und.
Also auch unabhängig davon ist das äh Wahlsystem von Hongkong und ich habe das nie ganz verstanden. Es gibt halt schon pro Distrikt, also äh äh jeden Bereich, also der geographischen Bereich Vertreter, dann gibt's aber auch Vertreter der,
Finanz äh arbeite und äh
Juristen und äh Computerspezialisten, also ähm fachspezifische ähm Vertreter, die dann auch in die NDR ins Parlament geschickt werden. Also ist alles,
mir recht unklar, ich habe mich da nicht richtig mit beschäftigt, aber in der Tat das Wichtige hier mitzunehmen ist, dass der äh das Staatsoberhaupt dann von der Volksrepublik China bestätigt werden muss,
so dass Hongkong sich nicht einfach so irgendjemanden wählen kann.
Und ist das dann Staatsüberhaupt oder ist das eher eine Oberbürgermeister.
Staatsoberhaupt. Weil ich meine, ist ja ein Land, zwei Systeme der Staatsoberhalt ist im Augenblick schien, bin in Peking. Ähm das.
Carrie Lam ist die CEO grade?
Schief Executive Officer ist die offizielle Bezeichnung des.
Es ist Rot quasi der Eindruck, äh Hongkong sei eine GmbH.
Quasi, wie hat das so sein? Ist ja sehr kommerziell und das passt eigentlich auch ganz gut. Sie verwaltet das dann halt so in aufträgerisch.
Aber das ist dann, wie viel, wie viel Millionen Menschen Wunder? Acht?
Acht Millionen plus.
Ungefähr, ja? Also in der Region, ne? Und die der.
Millionen in der ganzen, also der der offizielle Name ist auch Hongkong seit neunzehnhundertsiebenundneunzig Hongkong, SAR, Special Friesen, äh besondere Verwaltungszone,
Spezielle Verwaltungszone von China. Ähm das sind insgesamt acht Millionen plus Menschen im Augenblick, die da wohnen.
Und die befinden sich jetzt, die haben das,
die befinden sich in hundert Jahre fast, also sagen wir mal britischer Tradition. Ich meine, die haben ja jetzt nicht da sind jetzt nicht die ganze Zeit irgendwie mit Rover durch die Gegend gefahren, haben Kekse äh gegessen und Tee getrunken, aber.
Der Tee kommt ja aus China auch, also beziehungsweise aus Indien, also Tee trinken ist.
Okay.
Durchaus, aber nicht unbedingt in derselben Tradition, nein.
Aber nicht nicht aus aber aus anderen Kennchen. So und ähm haben,
also Hongkong hat eine enorme,
ökonomische Freizügigkeit will mir scheinen. Also ich habe, ich so schön ich diese Stadt finde, ist sie auch ja so der Begriff Turbokapitalismus kommt einem ja schon da,
den Sinn, woran liegt's? Wie, was, wie, es war mir völlig,
Unklar, dass irgendwie, ne, eine der wichtigsten ökonomischen Regionen von China, dass ja man meint eigentlich ein äh sozialistisches Land sei oder ein oder ein, sagen wir mal, ein.
Kommunistisch ein kommunistisches ähm Land zumindest äh da, auch was draufsteht, außen, aber ähm also China selber, die Volksrepublik China Kommunistische Volksrepublik.
So wie ich das verstanden habe, äh in Hongkong halt überhaupt nicht in der Tat, wie,
Turbokapitalismus ist da das richtige Wort, das ist schon ähm alles sehr auf äh ja Marktwirtschaft und Handel äh bedacht oder beziehungsweise darum gebaut, also wie gesagt, das sind acht Millionen Leute auf recht kleinem Raum. Da gibt's keine,
Kultur oder so. Ich höre Hongkong zuerst kennengelernt als Kind vor siebenundneunzig war das ähm Made in Hong Kong. War so ein bisschen was,
das stand da auf den Glühbirnen drauf oder es war auf irgendwelchen billigen Trainingsschuhen oder oder Jogginghosen gedruckt. Ähm heutzutage sagen würde, made in China äh war in den achtziger Jahren, siebziger Jahren halt noch,
in Hongkong gebaut, ne, halt billige Elektronik, also Unterhaltungselektrikel, Elektronik, ähm Klamotten, Textilien,
Ähm so habe ich das ursprünglich kennengelernt, diese Art Aspekte der äh Wirtschaft ist aber nun mehr nicht existent oder nur noch in ganz wenigen.
Wo haben die denn da produziert dann irgendwo in den New Territories und äh.
Ja oder auch in der Stadt, das war halt anders, damals noch nicht so dicht besiedelt und das hatte, also ich meine, das war jetzt auch keine Großindustrie oder Schwerindustrie, aber halt,
Menschenarbeit mit halt Handarbeit ging, die halt Sachen genäht, so stelle ich mir das zumindest vor
Ähm und daher kommt das also ursprünglich, aber heutzutage halt ausschließlich halt eins äh Finanzstandort und sie haben einen sehr großen Containerporting, wie den drittführt größten der Welt oder zumindest war das vor kurzer Zeit noch der Fall.
Den wollte ich grade ansprechen, weil äh also da ist das ist wirklich mein, ich habe jetzt den einen oder anderen Hafen schon gesehen,
aber das also was da an Pötten rein und rausfährt, ist äh wirklich,
sehr, sehr beeindruckend. Also ich glaube, das einzige wo ich mal mehr Schiffe auf einem Haufen gesehen habe, war irgendwie am Eingang von Panamakanal oder so, ne. Die da gewartet haben.
Sind aber kleinere Schiffe. Äh Panama.
Das sind ja äh genau, das sind die das sind die Panamakanal äh Maximalbreite äh Kähne.
Nee, das ist in der Tat und wenn man dann auf Lamme eine entwohnt, äh dann sieht man dann halt auch wirklich jeden Morgen vor seinem Fenster, da die Containerschiffe vorbeifahren, voller Playstations und iPhones,
von China in dem westliche Weltgeschiff werden, dann leer zurückfahren.
Island, wo du gewohnt hast, fand ich ja dann auch so nochmal so besonders erstaunlich, ne, also hier wohnst du in Berlin und,
Wenn du mal rausfahren willst in die Natur, dann fährst du etwas weiß ich nach Kronewald oder Müggelheim oder so, ne? Und und äh in Hongkong fährst du irgendwie, was ist das äh von Central mitm Schiff,
vierzig Minuten oder so.
Fünfundzwanzig, fünfundzwanzig Minuten bis auf der tropischen Insel. Je nachdem, also die fünfundzwanzig Minuten.
Die kurze Station, aber die Länge war da ein bisschen, aber okay, also vierundzwanzig Minuten. Fünfundzwanzig Minuten und bist auf einer auf einer Tropeninsel, auf der es keine äh Autos gibt.
Nur so kleine Wagens, zwei Takte, das sind zwei Takte dann.
Kleinen Quads, mit denen so kleine Zweitaktes, mit denen da die Bergrettung, äh die Leute äh abholt, wenn die sich den Fuß verknaxen auf einem der drei Wege. Oder, also mehr als drei Wege geht's da nicht. Einen Rundweg?
Prinzipiell ja alles sehr, sehr unbefestigt. Ja. Also wann der Weg.
Der also fand ich bärtstark und äh,
Ja, das muss man, glaube ich, schon erzählen. Du hast da, du hast auf dieser Insel gewohnt. Und das erste Mal, als ich dich besucht habe, war es irgendwie schon dunkel und auf dem Weg. Wir sind, glaube ich, mit der letzten Fähre rübergefahren.
Letzte Fähre ist die lustigste Fähre.
Fähre, klar und äh auf dem Weg hieß es schon sehr, hast du eigentlich eine Taschenlampe mit, weil natürlich ist diese Insel unbeleuchtet und es gibt da allerhand Tiere, äh in die man nicht reintreten möchte.
Äh Schlangen hauptsächlich, das ist das Problem. Ähm die
merken aber meistens, wenn man, wenn man ihnen zu nahe kommt und hauen dann vorher ab, ähm das wirklich problematisch ist, sind die hundertfüßler die Sentipies, ähm denen ist das ganz egal, ob du auf die zukommst oder nicht, äh die beißen dich dann trotzdem und das ist anscheinend auch extrem schmerzhaft.
Aber du hast es zehn Jahre geschafft, nicht von einem Gebissen zu werden.
Ich wurde noch nie von gebissen.
Obwohl du zwei im Haus hattest.
Die kamen immer mal wieder, das geht äh das kommt man auch nicht drum rum, weil die Häuser sind nicht so heimetisch konzipiert. Äh die merkt man dann auch immer mal, aber bisher hatte ich Glück.
Und dann noch diese diese großen Spinnen. Wo du sagtest, dass wir das wahrscheinlichste, dass ich einfach eine riesige Spinne im Gesicht habe, aber die macht nix.
Die Bananenspiders äh sehen extrem,
sah extrem schlimm aus, also so schwarz gelb und heller groß und so sind aber äh für Säugetiere im Allgemeinen ungefährlich für Menschen auf jeden Fall, also nicht giftig und ich habe einmal gesehen, dass sie so einen kleinen Kolibri im Netz hatten, aber auch ansonsten äh,
als Wirbeltier hat man da eigentlich keine Probleme mit denen.
Einen Heimweg? Ein Traum. Ich habe das, ich habe äh.
Wirklich schön, super tropisch, dann auch die Fledermäuse, die an den Bananen, Stauden, Naschen, abends und so äh Frösche zu bestimmten Saison und alles so sein, ja. Ist halt direkt vor der Haustür.
Wirklich, wirklich enorm schön und ein toller Spaziergang. Ja, also kann kann Brandenburg echt nicht gegen anstinken. Muss man jetzt einfach mal nahtlos anerkennen. Genau, da hast du gewohnt.
Sollte dazu noch erwähnen Linus Vollständigkeit halber, weil die Leute sich fragen könnten, hier acht Millionen Leute, wie kann man das bezahlen? Äh der Grund, weswegen Lammer Island das ein schöner Ort zu wohnen ist, ist, weil der auch so ein hässliches Kohlekraftwerk steht direkt am Strand.
Ähm das macht dann die Grundstückspreise entsprechend äh attraktiv, weil dann halt niemand richtig hinziehen will, insofern ist die ganze Insel voller.
Expats, wie ich, die da halt irgendwie Rotwein trinken, abends am Strand, denen das nicht so wichtig ist, aber ist halt.
Nicht genau dasselbe wie der Rest von Hong Kong, also auch die anderen Länder, äh die anderen äh Inseln, jetzt Landrat zum Beispiel.
Und du hattest natürlich einen etwas längeren Weg zur Arbeit, ne? Weil du ja den den Fußmarsch zum Hafen so oft vor die Fähre auch nicht, also für Hongkonger Verhältnisse wirklich sehr selten.
Ne, ist einmal die Stunde und dann in der Tat noch so eine halbe Stunde durch den Dschungel laufen und so, also da, das hat schon eine gewisse, das funktioniert nicht mit jedem, mit jedem Setup.
Aber das das Kraftwerk hat mal davon, da wo du gewohnt hast, überhaupt nicht gesehen. Es ist so so störend fand ich das auch nicht.
Nee, nee, aber das äh je nach Lungenkapazität und so ist das schon. Das mag also Freunde von mir sind auch schon mit dem Helikopter ausgeflogen worden, weil sie irgendwie,
nicht genug Luft bekommen haben, das war da zu viel, also das ist halt schon, ich meine es ist halt riesiges Kraftwerk irgendwie.
Was möchte ich sagen? Vielleicht so ein paar Zähne für Tänzen vertan, aber es gibt nur zwei Kraftwerke in Hong Kong, zwei Kohlekraftwerke. Eins davon eurer Flamme, die,
powern halt einen Großteil der der ganzen Stadt und den ganzen Lichtern und so. Und die lassen halt abends immer ihre Turbinen, also abends feiern, nachts feiern die ihre Turbinen verbrennen da die Kohle, um die Turbinen anzutreiben. Insofern,
sieht man eigentlich kein kein Rauch, weil halt abends und nachts und dunkel und so, aber.
Das ist halt das ist halt schon dreckig. Ja, du hast auch immer so einen Film aufm Balkon, ne. Also, so eine Staubschicht, kein richtiger Ruß, aber halt. Also man merkt das schon und die Luft ist nicht äh so schön, wie man das.
Ich habe mich immer gewundert, weil ich das immer nur tagsüber gesehen habe und dachte, ach ja hier, schön das ist aber ein modernes Kraftwerk, ist gar nicht an.
Es kann nicht handeln.
Ähm.
Wir haben jetzt also so so viel zu deiner deiner dann doch wie ich sagen muss echt sehr bemerkenswerten Wohnsituation da. Du hast gearbeitet in der IT.
Ja, Computer und System und Netzwerk, Architektur und Engineering für. Wer immer das brauchte.
Also wir bleiben vielleicht nochmal ganz kurz ein bisschen bei den Besonderheiten, weil was man von Hongkong immer hört, ist, da würden keine gäb's keine Steuern. Also gibt's auch nicht, wenn du was kaufst, muss keine, gibt's keine Umsatzsteuer zum Beispiel.
Schon mal gar nicht, also das äh das was ganz anderes,
ähm man zahlt schon Steuern, aber erstaunlich wenig und das ist auch nicht so schlimm, wenn man die nicht zahlt, dann muss man halt nächstes Jahr zahlen, also es gibt halt, es.
Ist nicht dasselbe wie hier, nicht dasselbe wie in Deutschland, ähm uns meines Verständnisses nach halt auch nicht ähm,
der Aspekt mit dem die Regierung ähm Geld bekommt, sondern vielmehr halt Land verkaufen, öffentliches Land ähm,
zu privatisieren und zu verkaufen, zu versteigern, ist anscheinend, wie die Hongkong Regierung Gipi, also die die ihre Elefants füllt, ähm die Steuern sind halt nur so ein,
so ein kleiner Nebenaspekt. Ich meine, das muss man dann schon zahlen, wenn man so an seiner seine äh seine permanente Staatsbürger in die Staatsbürgerschaft hat, Aufenthaltserlaubnis bekommen will, dann muss man irgendwann mal Steuern zahlen. Aber generell ist das schon alles sehr lachs und auch dann ist es halt,
zwölf, dreizehn Prozent oder so möchte ich sagen, also.
Also vernachlässigbar.
Insofern zum Grunde halt auch sehr viele Leute, das jetzt war für mich nicht direkt der Fall, aber wurden halt auch sehr viele Leute aus exaktem Grund dann dafür ein paar Jahre, ne.
Ach so, ja und äh und weil man da auch natürlich schön ähm Ferrari fahren kann.
Erstaunlicherweise, also eigentlich nicht, aber.
Muss, aber es muss unglaublich schön sein, da Ferrari zu fahren, weil äh so viele Ferraris habe ich, glaube ich, nirgendwo anders gesehen.
Also Hongkong, als wenn man wenn man sich für Autos interessiert, dann ist Hongkong der Platz, wo man wohnen kann, wo man dann auch jedes Jahr die neusten,
von allen möglichen italienischen und amerikanischen und was immer äh Marken, also Luxus, Luxusautos ähm sieht ähm da gibt's zum einen natürlich diese diese Hals,
ist ja ein Rennauto, das holt mich ja wahrscheinlich eher zum selber Fahren, aber halt auch die Limousinen, äh die die sieht man doch auch doch sehr häufig.
Aber nicht auf Flamme Island, deswegen wäre ich wer nach Lama Island gezogen, wenn ich wenn ich dort gewohnt hätte. Ähm durch den Hafen Zölle irgendwie import Export oder sowas, auch nicht großartig, oder?
Nee, ich glaube auch gar nicht, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, also Freihafen Hong Kong hat einen Freihafenstatus, wie ich das richtig verstanden habe, ist das halt so,
Du musst halt nichts bezahlen, um zu importieren oder zu exportieren, was natürlich auch sehr praktisch macht als Händler.
Das würde ich vermuten entspringt dann vielleicht der britischen Tradition schon, also das war wahrscheinlich doch einer der Gründe, warum die dieses diesen Felsen so spannend fanden, oder? Dort einen, einen interessanten Hafen zu errichten oder.
Auf jeden Fall. Also der ursprüngliche Hafen im Süden von Hongkong, der Air Berlin war, glaube ich, eher erstmal für die für die Flotte,
also die militärische, die ähm,
aber der Hafen, der heutzutage und dann halt auch seit den fünfziger Jahren oder so ähm immer weiter ausgebaut wird als als Umschlag ähm ja.
Knotenpunkt, ne? Also sowohl was halt Daten als auch ähm Güter angeht, das Hongkong halt auch wirklich direkt unterhalb von China und China ist halt,
Hersteller und zunehmend auch mehr als als Konsument natürlich schon sehr wichtig und liegt halt auch auf 'ne Route zwischen zum einen, also,
Korea und Japan und dann Indien auf der anderen Seite, das heißt man kommt da schon durch, wenn man, wenn man in welche Richtung man fährt,
Daher kommt das dann denke ich auch historisch.
Und Hongkong hat aufgrund seines Sonderstatuses also Hongkong wird,
nicht nur innerhalb von China mit einem Sonderstatus versehen, sondern natürlich auch in der Außen,
anders behandelt, von anderen Ländern, ne? Also es gibt irgendwie, wenn eine Exportrestriktion nach China gilt, dann geht die nicht notwendigerweise nach Hongkong.
Genau, das war halt dieser Sonderstatus. Der ist, glaube ich, auch von,
Neunzehnhundertzwoundneunzig, also auch vor dem Handover schon geschlossen worden, also hier spezifisch im Fall der Vereinigten Staaten. Hongkong Policy Act, der das halt alles ähm,
anders regelt. Das Salz solange Hongkong, ein anderes System hat als China, dass da dann halt.
Nicht direkt Waffen, aber halt irgendwie Hochtechnologie, die ansonsten restriktiert wäre zur Auslieferung zur Lieferung nach China dann halt in Hongkong einfach gekauft werden darf, also was immer Mikropasisoren und Grafikkarten und sowas, GPS Systeme und so.
Also man muss sich das eigentlich ungefähr so vorstellen.
Also ich finde, das passt so irgendwie mit den Konzepten, die man davon hat, so überhaupt nicht zusammen. Das wäre, als würde die,
die, sage ich mal, die jetzigen Deutschland in seinen als wäre die demokratische Republik,
demokratische, deutsche Republik in den jetzigen Grenzen der BRD und würde sich so München und Stuttgart als kapitalistische Enklaven,
leisten, ja? Und im Rest des Landes äh gilt gilt Zucht und Ordnung und ähm dort äh geben wir Vollgas, um irgendwie,
Ja, also warum auch, warum äh also warum war mir also klar, um irgendwie vielleicht den so einen so ein Labor für,
für ungehinderten Fortschritt zu haben.
Ja, warum es heute gute Frage, also im Sinne von, weswegen ist China auf das auf den Deal überhaupt eingegangen? Ursprünglich, aber neunzehnhundertvierundachtzig war das halt auch eine andere Regierung. Er ist heutzutage da auch nochmal.
Auf 'n anderen Level, also seit neunzehnhundertvierundachtzig hat sich die chinesische Wirtschaft, ich weiß nicht wie viel, aber.
Nicht verdoppelt, sondern halt verxfacht. Das sind äh das ist äh exponentielles Wachstum oder was. Ähm,
damals hat er es schon sehr viel Sinn gemacht, also Hongkong einfach als halt wirklich einseitig.
Als Wirtschaftseinkommen zu haben, wobei ich nicht ganz verstehe, wo das Einkommen herkommt, weil wir gerade gesagt haben, dass es eben kein Ex-Inport-Export äh Zölle gibt, ähm aber nichtsdestotrotz da halt auf jeden Fall aber halt ähm,
alter Handel dadurch passiert ist, was den Rest von China nicht der Fall war. Ähm insofern hat das sehr viel Sinn gemacht. Und wie gesagt, also ich meine, das war ja halt auch der eine der Bedingungen, weswegen das überhaupt äh die die Grundkolonie zurückgegeben wurde,
halbwegs freiwillig war von von den Engländern. Ähm das hat sich halt mittlerweile geändert und deswegen hat sich auch die Situation vor Ort geändert, würde ich sagen.
Und es hat sich auch noch etwas ganz anderes geändert, was wir, äh warum ich über diese Stadt auch hier im Lokbuch Netzpolitik mit dir sprechen wollte, nämlich,
in dieser gleichen Zeit. Also wenn wir jetzt wieder zurückguckt, ne? Ich meine, neunzehnhundertsiebenundneunzig begann,
so langsam die Digitalisierung in die Breite zu gehen, ja? Dass jetzt irgendwie Menschen begannen,
sich Internetanschlüsse in ihre Häuser zu legen, die nicht aus Nordfamilien kamen.
Analoge Internetanschlüsse damals aber ja das hat ungefähr die Zeit also halt dann DSL und RTS.
Er kam dann so, ne, irgendwann.
Ersten zwei G-Telefone und so, das ist ja, ja.
Also all dieses all diese mobile äh also genau der Mobilkram kam so Ende der neunziger in die in die Breite. Klar es gab vorher zehn Netze und so, die die Besten von uns erinnern sich,
ähm,
aber die mit diesem Handover beginnt parallel diese Entwicklung, dass die Menschheit überall auf der Welt sich mit diesem Internet auseinandersetzt und China,
hat damit,
eigentlich Probleme, die möchten ja nicht diesen diesen freien Informationsaustausch so unbedingt haben und es gibt in China etwas, was sich äh.
Genau, die ist die Golden Schild, die Firewall, die größte Firewall, die man auch aus dem Weltall noch sehen kann und bloß im Auge. Ähm also sprich, es ist eine andere, äh eine andere Art von,
Netzkultur. Äh vielleicht gehen wir dann später noch mal ein bisschen genauer drauf ein. Ich wollte nochmal erwähnen, weil du eben Enklave gesagt hast, also man kann's jetzt eher so vorstellen, dass so seltsam,
Genau, ist halt kein Enklave.
Nicht. Nee, es ist keine.
Wenn jetzt Hamburg oder Kiel irgendwie in der Freihandelszone wären oder sowas, ne, halt das liegt halt am Wasser,
Und oben drüber ist China, das ist äh ein wichtiger Unterschied, weil du halt da,
Sowohl mit dem Schiff hinfahren kannst, ohne China zu gehen, aber halt auch äh die Unterseekabel da anlanden und das dann halt spezifisch in Zeiten der der äh Finanzpolitik äh globalen,
Finanzmärkte ebenfalls ein sehr wichtiger Aspekt der ganzen Sache ist.
Unbedingt, sehr.
Also wenn man sich diese diese Kabel anschaut, also spezifisch so
Optik Linka. Ähm vielleicht das Bekannteste, das kennt man ja von Nils Stevenson, der hat das auch in den Neunzigern schon mal beschrieben. Ähm das kommt halt direkt auch wieder. Man fängt natürlich in Europa an,
Ähm geht um nichts Rote mehr. Äh nach Indien. Und dann von unter Malaysia an Singapur vorbei, Singapur natürlich ebenfalls an ähnliche,
Metropole wie Hongkong äh in der Richtung geht dann halt von Singapur nach Hongkong rüber und geht dann auch von da aus direkt nach Korea und und Japan weiter ohne halt durch China durchzugehen. Das heißt, dass dieses Enklavending das also Schwankungen ist kein Enklave von China, sondern es hängt.
Da dran und hat halt dann diese sowohl Seewege als auch die die Fiberoptikwege, die dann überhaupt nicht mit China zusammenhängen.
Und deswegen auch ordentliches Internet.
Es ist halt weit weg durch die Lichtgeschwindigkeit immer noch ein bisschen, also zweihundert Millisekunden von von Europa weit weg, das ist schon je nachdem, was man, welche Latenz man so als Day-Trader braucht, nicht unbedingt das Beste, aber es ist halt nicht gefiltert. Also das hat,
weil's halt unter äh nicht direkt unter chinesische ähm äh Oberstaatsoberhaupt steht, Staatsobigkeit steht. Ähm kommen da einfach die,
du es halt direkt am internationalen quasi dran und bisher gab's auch in der Tat, wie du gesagt hast, Linus, da auch keine oder beziehungsweise nur sehr minimale Restriktionen im Internet. Weniger als in Deutschland oder in den USA würde ich behaupten.
Gab's da überhaupt welche? Also was was würdest du als Restriktion da bezeichnen? Ich ähm.
Na ja, also ich meine, ich sage mal so, also.
Kim Schmitz hatte auch seinen früher in Hongkong gehabt und das hat er dann irgendwann nicht mehr. Ich meine, irgendwie scheint schon auf bestimmten,
wahrscheinlich eher äh marktwirtschaftlichen äh äh Kräften zufolge scheinen, weil Leute schon äh was weiß ich aus Datencenter gekickt worden zu sein oder so. Aber jetzt spielt einfach so den.
Der Internetverkehr als solches ähm sollte recht.
Zumindest lange Zeit keine technischen Filter, so wie ich das verstehen habe, also keine Content-Filter, so wie ich das verstanden habe ähm und halt auch keine Gesetzgebung, weil halt Hongkong auch von der,
muss man auch ganz wichtig dazu erwähnen, halt auch von der, von der ähm Kultur her, also von der von der ähm Gesetzgebung her relativ freie Meinungsäußerung.
Also in Hongkong darf zu harten Kreuze an die Wand sprühen, das ist keine Straftat, das ist auch ganz gut, weil die buddhistischen, vegetarischen Restaurants ja natürlich alle Hakenkreuze haben, die da links rum drehen, ähm aber das meine ich, ne, das äh.
Da muss man sich äh muss man sich in vielen Regionen Asiens dran gewöhnen, dass sie sich überall Hakenkreuze hinmalen.
Äh vielleicht gibt's ja noch an, also es gibt ja noch andere Bereiche der Meinungsäußerung, die uns vielleicht interessieren. Zum Beispiel, was man ja immer wieder hört, ist, dass äh,
China eine Internetkontrolle hat, die es verhindern will, dass Menschen sich über.
Die Auseinandersetzung des Massaker am Platz des himmlischen Friedens informieren.
Also vierter Juni neunzehnhundertsechsundachtzig, dann reden wir nochmal ein bisschen über was ihr das Golden Schild eigentlich ist, also in der Tat, also es gibt verschiedene Themen. Wie du sagst, die die äh gewaltige ähm
gewalttätige Unterdrückung der Proteste im China neunzehnhundertsechsundachtzig ein sehr gutes Beispiel dafür, aber natürlich auch der Status von
zum Beispiel ist das Teil von China oder nicht, äh spezifisch der Status von Taiwan ist die Republik von China, Taiwan, ein,
Nationalstaat oder nicht, da sind Leute geteilte Meinungen drüber. Ähm es gibt bestimmte Themen, die einfach den Äußerungen oder Verbreitung in China illegal sind.
Oder zumindest auch genauso verfolgt werden, auch wenn sie nicht explizit illegal sind, dass halt dann China alles noch ein bisschen äh komplizierter ist, sich da zurechtzufinden und zu sagen.
Nicht so klar gesagt, was erlaubt ist zu sagen und was nicht. Aber es gibt halt, wie gesagt, diese bestimmten Themen und die Golden Sheld Firewall ist dann halt,
Technologie, die dafür sorgt, dass du das dann auch nicht siehst. Also ich meine, generell ist es so, China hat halt schon,
IPV vier und es ist schon verbunden mit dem Rest vom Internet, ne? Das ist halt schon prinzipiell dasselbe,
Teil desselben globalen Netzwerks auf einen bestimmten Ebene, ne? Man kann dazwischen rauten, mehr oder weniger. Aber diese goldenen ist halt auf allen.
Stricken, die aus dem Manager, aus der Volksrepublik nach außen führen,
Sind halt Filter dazwischen. Früher haben die so funktioniert, dass die einfach mitgelesen haben, die TCP-Connections. Und wenn die jetzt bei Wikipedia dann halt den den äh Platz des himmlischen Friedensartikels aufgemacht hast, hat er dann in Kitas mitgelesen. Ein Keyword erkannt,
und die Verbindung dann.
Das ist.
An beide Seiten geschickt hat, die und die dann aufgelegt hat auf beiden Seiten der Browser beide dachten.
Die TCP Session ist jetzt vorbei. Genau. Der andere will nicht mehr.
Genau. Wie das in Zeiten von SSL und TLS funktioniert, ist mir nicht so richtig klar, habe ich mir jetzt nicht weiter angeguckt, aber generell ist es so, es geht halt technisch nicht,
von irgendeinem beliebigen Platz in China sich dann einfach bestimmte Wikipedia-Seiten aufzurufen. Und das ist nicht bei Wikipedia das äh selbst zensiert, weil sowas gibt's ja auch, sondern es ist halt, weil da Filter dazwischen sind,
die auf dem Weg aus China raus zu den Wikipedia Servern das dann halt merken und dann halt verhindern.
Das ist das ist ein unglaublicher Aufwand, ne. Also das kostet ja ein Schweinegeld, diese Technologie zu machen.
Damit kann man sehr viel Geld verdienen und das ist auch keine chinesische Technologie, die da eingesetzt wird.
Meinst du, die machen das alles auf Sisco? Oder.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das Disco ist, aber ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass da äh auch westliche Technologie zum Einsatz kommt.
Und okay, aber der wichtige Faktor, wir wollen ein bisschen bei äh
Hongkong bleiben, also kein kein freier Zugang, kein freier, unkontrollierter Zugang zum Internet. Es gibt eine Informationskontrolle, es gibt äh also eine Zensur äh und mit Sicherheit auch eine Überwachung. Ich meine, diese Sachen gehen Hand in Hand.
In China. Und in Hongkong war das lange Zeit nicht der Fall.
In Hongkong war das nicht der Fall, was eben zu einem ja doch wirklich äh.
Da hat man ohnehin in vielen großen Städten Asiens, du hast jetzt auch irgendwie Tokio oder Singapur genannt.
Wann kommt sich dann hier so als Berliner Provinzler schon wirklich ein bisschen ähm schwer unterentwickelt vor, ne? Wenn man sich anguckt, dass die was weiß ich,
pünktlich fahrende Züge haben, schnelles Internet, ähm.
Ja, Internet auch überall, also das ist auch wirklich so kein, also,
Kein Netz gibt's nicht, also sogar auf der Insel, wenn ich mit der Fähre auf die Insel fahre, dann habe ich da habe ich da mein volle vier Signalbäume empfangen unter äh in der U-Bahn und alles, das ist schon alles anständig ausgerollt.
Ist das teuer? Internet.
Nö, das kostet auch irgendwie zehn Euro im Monat maximal, das ist schon alles.
Irgendwelche starken Limitationen auf die Bandbreite, Netzneutralitätsverletzungen, irgendwas, was uns was uns das Paradies hier noch äh unschön machen würde, also so irgendwelche irgendwas Kleingedrucktes, nee, ne?
Ja generell nicht, nee, also das wird auch schon immer na gut, man muss das schon auch, also das sind halt dann auch nur vier Telekom-Konzerne, die sich das dann untereinander aufteilen. Ähm und da gibt's natürlich schon, also ich denke.
Einer mehr als bei uns.
Ja in der Tat. Ähm also ganz, ganz, ganz so, also meine ist halt Kapitalismus ist halt keine staatliche Warzung, das ich da gewohnt habe, keine staatliche Kontrolle und so, aber war halt trotzdem halt Wettbewerb der Anbieter gegeneinander, also,
in Hongkong war das auch die ganze Zeit so, dass die Namenserver, wenn ich da irgendeine URL falsch angegeben habe im Browser, dann hat der Namenserver von meinem Internet Provider mir auch.
Zugeballert.
Seine E-Mail, seine Internetadresse gegeben und da dann halt mehr Produkte angeboten, also das gibt's ja halt schon, aber halt, wie gesagt, keine zentralisierte Kontrolle.
Okay, also ein Leben äh mit mit allerlei Vorzügen.
Jetzt müssen wir trotzdem auch mal ein bisschen, also wir haben ja gesagt, was äh du bist Expert dort gewesen. Mich interessiert schon, wie das war. Du bist aus einer Stadt mit hunderttausend Einwohnern oder zweihundert.
Irgendwie nach Hongkong gezogen.
In der Tat, ich wusste auch nicht so viel über Hongkong, ursprünglich wollte ich auch nur ein Jahr da bleiben, das war so, ich war mit dem Studium fertig, wollte nicht direkt arbeiten gehen und hat dann so ursprünglich einen Job angenommen bei so einem äh Computerspiel, Hardwareversand,
die Website zu machen, das war ursprünglich nur für zwölf Monate geplant, die haben mich halt dahin geflogen und äh,
Ich brauche euren Arbeitgeber, den man da wohnen kann, ähm erstmal mit deutschem Pass. Beziehungsweise das Land ist deutlich einfacher, wenn man einen Arbeitgeber hat, der einen dann das sponsert. Insofern war das ursprünglich so, ich schaue mir das mal zwölf Monate an und überlege mir, was ich als nächstes mache,
bin dann halt da hängen geblieben, das ist ganz schnell zehn Jahre geworden, die Stadt ist super schnell, sehr rasant, das heißt, das merkt man auch gar nicht so richtig,
wie schnell die Zeit vergeht, aber nee, das war schon was anderes, da im Vergleich zum beschaulichen Deutschland, halt alles deutlich schneller. Ähm,
Mein erster Eindruck war halt wirklich, dass es fünfzehn Jahre in der Zukunft, ich lebe hier so ein Cyber Punk leben schon, was halt, weil halt,
Also einmal die ganzen Neon- und Elite äh Reklame, die halt wirklich die Stadt,
blau und gelb und grün und immer wechselnd und flimmert machen. Grad bei Regen halt wirklich so ein so ein Blade Runner Ästhetik, die man da automatisch schon hat, ne. Dann, wie du gesagt hast, halt die Telefone überall und also die,
Verbindung, also die äh Erreichbarkeit überall, aber es ist halt auch so, alle Leute in Hongkong haben halt ein Zelt voran. Das ist mittlerweile in Deutschland vielleicht auch nicht mehr so außergewöhnlich, aber.
Zweitausendsechs war das noch nicht so, dass,
Leute in jedem Alter, in jeder Generation, mit dem Telefon in der U-Bahn sitzen und da dann irgendwie Bird spielen oder so, aber in Hongkong ist das wirklich so ein.
Generationenübergreifend einfach, das macht halt, machen halt alle Leute so. Und dann, wie gesagt, halt dadurch, dass es halt so eine internationale Stadt ist, halt Leute aus der ganzen Welt da irgendwie aufeinander treffen, aber das alles sehr, sehr spannend.
Und trotzdem nicht so, also hm also auch wenn das alles so also es ist alles so modern aber ich finde auch also eine Sache, die Blade Runner ja so ein bisschen zumindest heute ausmacht ist, dass der Film, wann wird der gedreht achtziger Jahre.
Ungefähr, ne, dass also Teile von Hongkong sehen trotzdem so ein bisschen retro aus,
Es ist nicht alles nur modern, sondern du hast auch immer noch irgendwelche was weiß ich, geilen Streetfood, Handkarren, die da irgendwie an dem parkenden Ferrari vorbeifahren, so.
Absolut, also Hongkong, Hongkong ist, ist eine Stadt der Gegensätze, das ist auch das Faszinierende dran, das ist auch was ich mit Cyber Punk meine wohlgemerkt das so
halt hast du halt die Ferraris und was immer und die alten Damen mit mit denen die ihre Handkarren mit in die alten Aluminiumbüchsen irgendwie da durch die Gegend schieben nebeneinander. Du hast halt so Bereiche und super Abend. Da ist super alt und super neu, alles halt sehr kompakt
auf auf engstem Räumen, also die Gegensätze sind das eine Kontraste. Äh sind da nicht zu übersehen.
Wie sind denn da eigentlich die Lebenserhaltungskosten? Also mir kam das.
Ist teuer,
alles andere ist billig. Also man kann da sehr einfach, sehr gut, billig essen gehen, chinesisch essen, beziehungsweise dann halt nicht Chinesisch, sondern kantunesisch, spezifisch oder Peking oder also
Es gibt halt sehr viel gutes Essen aus China und aus der ganzen Welt und das kostet alles überhaupt nichts. Äh was alles, was,
irgendwie Platz braucht, ist super teuer. Also die Miete ist für ein deutlich kleineres, wie gesagt, wenn auf Toilette sitzt, kannst du immer mit deiner Hand ausgestreckt die Wand erreichen. Da,
Alles alles super eng. Ähm.
Miete kostet halt genauso viel wie in wie in Berlin. Heutzutage noch eine eine geräumige, mehrere Zimmerwohnung. Ähm das heißt, dafür zahlen Leute dann ein Drittel bis die Hälfte ihres ihres Einkommens äh einfach nur für die Miete und alles, was damit zu tun hat,
egal ob's jetzt irgendwie ist oder,
Storage von von irgendwelchen Sachen da oder was immer oder halt Filmstudios oder so, alles wo du viel Platz brauchst, ist richtig teuer.
Und du äh,
aber also kann man dann noch an sein an dem kulturellen Angeboten dort teilnehmen, weil es gibt ja unglaublich viele geile Sachen, die man da machen kann, ne? Und irgendwie so draußen rumhängen, es scheint aber nicht unbedingt,
ähm das Hong, der der Honkey Style zu sein, ne, also.
Das machen dann nur die Expats, wie gesagt, die sitzen dann gerne am Strand und trinken Rotwein abends, äh aber das ist nicht nicht so generell der Style, der der ähm,
der Honko, das Hongkong ist an sich, ähm das öffentliche Leben ist teuer, wenn man halt wirklich alles dann, also,
Ist halt sehr viel Konsum, also in der Tat sind auch die meisten öffentlichen Plätze, sondern Einkaufszentren. Da verbringt man dann diese auch prima gekühlt, ne? Das will man ja auch nicht draußen sein bei der bei der Hitze immer. Das heißt, man geht dann halt Samstags,
in die Mall, statt an den Strand. Ähm insofern gibt man dann halt auch Geld aus. Ähm je nachdem äh wie TT monetären äh Materialien äh Möglichkeiten, die man hat, ist man halt auch von bestimmten Sachen einfach ausgeschlossen. Das ist durchaus und das ist halt auch,
in der Ordnung, die Hongkong, hervorruft, deshalb habe ich seine, ja, unterschiedliche Soziotope entstehen.
Es gibt da noch diese diese Nennkultur.
Okay, richtig, was hatten wir noch eigentlich erwähnt? Äh äh.
Das sind nämlich auch Menschen, die man an einem Tag in der Woche war, dass Freitag sonntags.
Touristic Helpes, also Haushaltshelfer aus spezifisch den Philippin, Philippin Islands, dem Philippinen und ähm Indonesien.
Haben spezielle, dafür, für diese beiden Länder gibt's spezielle Visa-Konstrukte, wo halt.
Ungebildete, wenig gebildete, ausschließlich Frauen,
aus diesen Ländern nach Hongkong ziehen dürfen, um dann bei einer Familie zu wohnen,
im Haus ähm in der Wohnung und für die zu kochen und die Kinder zur Arbeit zu bringen und dann natürlich zu putzen und die Kinder von der Arbeit abzufeiern, die Kinder zur Schule zu bringen, die Kinder von der Schule wieder abzuholen,
dann wieder wieder Abendessen zu kochen und prinzipiell halt alles, was einen so ein bisschen stört. Ne, was man hier in Berlin mit der Hand macht oder wenn man Glück hat, eine Spülmaschine hat oder so, aber halt das so staubsaugen und einkaufen gehen und,
alle, alle Kurs, Kurs, wenn dann, wenn dann von den gemacht und in der Tat haben die halt sechs Tage die Woche zu tun,
Ist aber gesetzlich vorgeschrieben, dass mindestens ein Tag dann äh frei haben müssen. Das ist dann der Sonntag. Und deswegen ist der Sonntag dann auch ganz anders in Hongkong, weil da dann.
Ist die Stadt voll von auf einmal einer anderen also äh ganz äh also erstmal sind an Orten auf einmal Unmengen an Menschen. Klar, die sind auch erkennbar alle nicht Chinesisch.
Und äh die die hängen halt draußen rum. Weiß ich nicht, weil sie.
Bei der Familie,
bleiben dürfen oder wollen, ne? Weil ich meine, die wollen sich halt untereinander treffen und das ist dann in der Tat einfach in irgendwelchen äh U-Bahnstationen oder halt auch lustigerweise direkt unter den großen Banking, also unter der Bank Offiner oder unter der AgelsBC.
Weil die Schatten spenden oder warum?
Ja, weil das einfach so Architektur ist, wo da halt Platz ist,
gilt dann als öffentlicher Platz und das in der Sonntags hat auch keine Bänke und dann ist das halt auf einmal alles super bunt und riecht lecker vom ganzen Essen, was sie sich mitbringen und dann kochen und so. Ähm das endet sich die ganze Stadt an, an sonntags.
Und das ist aber ein, also ist ein quasi ein Zeichen von deren ökonomischen Status, dass sie sich eben draußen treffen, weil man würde das nicht machen.
Also ich meine, du kommst irgendwie,
irgendwo als Jakarta, kommst alleine mit achtzehn oder neunzehn nach Hongkong, kennst du niemanden erstmal und wohnst halt wohlgemerkt auch bei deinem Arbeitgeber irgendwie im Flur oder so. Also, das ist äh,
nach gesetzlich erlaubt, aber so muss ich mir das vorstellen, ne? Kleine Wohnung und dann irgendwie zwei Kinder und,
Also generell, du willst ausm Haus. Aber wo willst du hin? Weil dann kannst du halt wirklich.
Fünfzig PL. Einfach dann auch nur halt auf der Freundin auf der Straße oder im Park treffen. So viele Parks gibt's auch nicht, auf jeden Fall nicht so viel irgendwie in Berlin und insofern. Ja, daher kommt was.
Haben die Frauen da irgendwie eine Perspektive? Also dass sie, außer, dass sie.
Also könnt ihr dann einen Wohlstand aufbauen oder kommen die aus dieser Kindeserziehungsnummer nochmal raus oder verbringen die einfach nur ihre besten Jahre dann mit anderen Leuten die Kinder groß zu ziehen?
Ja, relativ, also ich meine, was man da? Ich meine, es ist wirklich nicht viel, was man verdient, das ist äh Freunde von mir,
diesen hat diese diesen Hintergrund ähm und das sind halt irgendwie hundert,
Euro oder so, die du dann im Monat bekommst, also erst gibt's ja nichts aus für Essen und Schlafen, ne, da ist ja so Aupair-Mädchen prinzipiell,
Sowann hast du wenig Kosten und das Geld schicken die dann normal auch einfach an ihre Familie. Also zumindest von den Leuten, die ich kenne, das wird dann in Indonesien und Philippinen irgendwie aufm Land oder,
in großen Städten ist das nochmal deutlich mehr wert, das Geld. Das heißt, da der Wohlstand wird dann eher ähm,
diese Länder ähm überwiesen, also das was das eingenommene Kapital wird überwiesen und dann gibt's auch viele Leute, die sich dann wenn sie's alles richtig gemacht haben, dann zurückziehen können und da dann halt zum Anfang der Existenz dann halt bei sein Land kaufen kannst oder Kühe oder?
Hühner oder so, also da also Freunde von mir haben sich damit mit harter,
Putzarbeit. Jetzt war jetzt grad meine Freundin, war jetzt nicht hat jetzt nicht bei jemandem irgendwie zur äh nicht bei jemandem gewohnt und geputzt, sondern einfach.
Prinzipiell so Putzhilfe irgendwie, halt vielen verschiedenen Leuten immer die Wohnung aufgeräumt jeden Tag und hat sich damit aber genug Geld erarbeitet mit harter händischer Arbeit, um dann halt äh in ihre,
Familie in Indonesien eine halbwegs anscheinend. Letzte, was ich gehört habe, gutgehende äh Manufaktur aufzubauen für so ähm,
Maisbrötchen oder Zutaten für Mais, Tortillas. Also das ist halt schon, also ich meine, das ist überhaupt, also die steht am untersten Ende der der Ökonomie in Hongkong,
Also alle Leute, die aus China und natürlich die westlichen Expats noch mehr haben, haben deutlich mehr Geld zum Ausgeben in Hongkong. Aber es ist ein erstaunliches,
höheres, also Einkommenpotential, als was so in Indonesien oder Philippinen einfach so hast, insofern sind die Leute, die das Geld zurückschicken, das ist,
da es dann also ein bisschen existenz äh auf Bau schon in bestimmten Fällen möglich, ja. Viele denken natürlich auch, weil es,
Siebzehnjährige Mädchen halbwegs verträumt und irgendwie viele zu viel Roman zu viel romantische Filme gesehen,
suchen sich natürlich dann auch irgendwie einen Mann, der sich in sie verliebt und dann von da an alles für sie übernimmt. Deswegen ist es auch ein sehr hässlicher Aspekt der ganzen Sache, dass dann junge gut aussehende Frauen,
Intelligente und gut aussehende Frauen aus armen Regionen der Welt sich dann mit,
treffen in irgendwelchen Bars, die natürlich auch einsam sind und alleine unter irgendjemanden haben. Äh und dann sich da.
Mehr oder weniger langfristig und mehr oder weniger gleichberechtigt. Kennen und lieben lernen. Ähm das ist durchaus eine Dynamik, die äh sehr viel auch gerade in der Kneipenkultur in Hongkong äh sehr viel, sehr, sehr im Vordergrund steht.
Das ist mir da nämlich auch aufgefallen, also so dieses ähm ich habe zumindest,
Wenn ich hier in Berlin äh mal eine Kneipe besuche, nicht unbedingt den Eindruck, dass dort,
nur Männergruppen und Frauengruppen irgendwie lauern. Ja und und eine Agenda haben an dem Abend so, ne, irgendwie so mit weiß sie nicht dann und dann fährt die letzte Bahn,
die oder die muss jetzt, wenn wenn der mit denen nix wird, müssen wir den nächsten also irgendwie so völlig ähm.
Also sehr, ja, klar, mit mit Zielsetzung äh da ausgegangen wird oder was was.
Immer noch der schönere Aspekt der ganzen Sache. Also ich meine es gibt auch,
einfach nur Prostitution, also Mädchen aus Thailand, die dann einfach nur für zwei Wochen auf so einem Touristenwieser da sind. Ey, extra, wenn irgendeine Messe
stattfindet in Hongkong, wo dann irgendwie Handelsvertreter aus der ganzen Welt für ein Wochenende irgendwie in der Stadt sind, ohne ihre Familien oder wenn so ein Flugzeugträger der amerikanischen irgendwie anlegt, da dann irgendwie tausende von Soldaten auf einmal Landgang haben.
Dann hast du halt auch einfach Sexarbeiter, die dann extra dafür,
nach Hongkong kommen und das nochmal deutlich klarere materielle Austausch als bei der halbwegs romantischen Idee, dass ich da irgendwie der einsame Westler mit der mit der mit der verträumten Prinzessin aus Indonesien in sie verliebt.
Okay, also wir haben, denke ich, die unschönen Aspekte.
Eine Stadt der Gegensätze und der Kontraste und deswegen alles super spannend und ganz anders als in Berlin. Deswegen war das auch so einfach, da zehn Jahre hängen zu bleiben.
Kann ich gut verstehen, also ich bedaure, dass ich zehn Jahre in Berlin hängengeblieben bin. Ähm aber wir wir müssen uns natürlich die Frage stellen, Partyszene Hong Kong.
Mir hat's sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Ich habe da auch äh nette nette Freunde kennengelernt. Äh also generell.
Man verbringt den Abend in irgendwelchen Rooftop-Bars oder äh was ist der der typische Hongkong Samstag Saturday Night.
Ja, wie gesagt, also ich meine, da sind meine Erfahrungen nicht typisch, weil meine Freunde sind alle cool und das sind die gehen dann einfach an den Strand und
trinken da und tanzen, das ist schon alles, das geht da auch, man hat da Platz für, aber das ist nicht typisch für Hongkong, das ist halt mehr so teure Cocktails in irgendwelchen Rooftop-Bars trinken,
ja, also schon sehr viel Alkohol, Alkohol ist da schon Kolonie und insofern Trinkkultur ist da auch nochmal anders als in Berlin.
Sonst noch was, äh was wir so ein bisschen über dein Leben oder über das Leben in Hongkong besprechen möchten.
Ja, also als, wie gesagt, als Softwareexperte, ähm das Interessante dadran ist natürlich, wie gesagt, dass direkt unter Shen, der speziellen, ökonomischen Zone ist, Chen Gin.
Alle Raute und Telefone und Kameras und was immer, also Unterhaltungselektronik äh der ganzen Welt prinzipiell herkommt, also halt gebaut wird, beziehungsweise in Kanton China halt die ganzen Fabriken stehen,
den Menschen dann ähm die Telefone zusammenbauen und die Playstations und so. Ähm das führt halt also zum einen ist es super geil, weil man kann dann nach fahren einfach
am Wochenende unter einkaufen gehen
oder einfach nur jetzt spezifisch eine genaue LED, die man noch nicht genau weiß, wie die aussehen soll, aber die haben die Haltung zu finden,
auch total Spaß da einfach durch die Maus durchzugehen, ebenfalls alles super kapitalistisch da, aber also wenn man sich,
Technik und Spezifik für Hardware und Elektronik interessiert, das ist schon geil, das ist schon der Ort, wo man sein will, für sowas und das hat dann halt auch den Effekt, dass da interessante Leute,
in der Stadt durch, durch die Stadt durchkommen, ne? Deshalb haben wir auch einen Hacker Space am Labs, muss man an der Stelle auch mal ähm.
Und das war Leuten, die da die ganze Zeit waren, aber kamen halt immer Menschen,
mal kurz in die Stadt, weil sie halt irgendeine coole Idee hatten, irgendein Produkt für irgendein oder eine Armbanduhr oder sowas, wo es halt jetzt einfach mal ein paar Prototypen machen wollten oder die Frau fertig waren, dann für die ähm,
Das heißt, du hast halt einfach eine ganze Menge, bist halt sehr nah dran an, was halt so in der Textzene gerade passiert. Die kommen da alle da durch und die Lampen dann auch trinken in den Cocktailbars abends.
Muss man vielleicht nochmal, also für Leute, die jetzt nicht nicht so kennen, das war, glaube ich, bis neunzehnhundertachtzig ein Fischerdorf,
Da liegt doch, glaube ich, irgendwo auch in in liegt noch irgendwie ein so ein so ein Holzboot, um irgendwie daran zu erinnern. Äh und heute ist das äh irgendwie eine Stadt mit ungefähr zwanzig Millionen Einwohnerinnen.
Je nachdem wie viel man erzählt, aber er hat das also deutlich größer als Hongkong und halt auch exponentielles Wachstum und ich meine, ich bin da dann alle zwei Monate oder so oder drei Monate mal hingefahren, eine Zeit lang,
und hat man, dann hat man trotzdem noch gesehen, dass die neue Hochhäuser schon wieder jetzt, das ist schon.
Das ist genau, also deshalb kannst du halt mitgucken, wie die Stadt wächst. Ähm das ist wirklich Boomtown. Ist ganz erstaunlich.
Also da ich war da ja auch mal ähm auf deinen äh auf deine Empfehlung. Ähm.
Märkte, also eher Indoor, ne, weil also irgendwie, keine Ahnung, eigentlich eine Maul, wo Leute, ja, wie du schon sagst, äh Elektronik Components verscheuern.
Bei der Miete. Ja. Genau. Genau.
Genau und ähm da findet aber natürlich auch in diesem in dieser,
Umgebung finde ich auch sehr viel der Elektronikfertigung statt, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, die jetzt hier so aus Deutschland dann so, ja ich will hier mal ein PCB, dass das mal jetzt fertigen, das das passiert dann irgendwie im Zweifelsfall in oder.
Ja, kommt drauf an, wie viel du wie viel PCBs du von einer Sorte haben willst, also du kannst halt, wenn du wenn du selber Hardware
Hardware Prototyping machen willst, hast du halt so irgendwie zwei Stunden, du machst halt das Layout am Computer, wenn du bist und dann,
Schickst du das jemanden und dann kommt ein Kurier mit seinem mit dem Board dann, also,
Das geht sehr schnell. Ich weiß nicht, ob's zwei Stunden sind, sehr Softwareexperte, aber halt Stunden und nicht Tage, in denen du.
Oder Wochen und Monat.
Für für einfach jetzt hier von dem Layout. Wir haben jetzt mal was geändert. Lass uns doch mal probieren. Äh die kriegst du dann auch sofort zurück, kannst du dann testen. Äh insofern das kommt alles, also aus diesen Hardwarestudios in Shengin und dann natürlich auch die Produktion von wegen
zufrieden mit Revision C, äh jetzt wollen wir die gerne fünf Millionen mal haben, das passiert dann auch in den Fabriken um Shanji, also auch innerhalb von noch denke ich, aber halt außerhalb,
den du gesehen hast.
Also du bist äh ich ich habe irgendwie den Eindruck, dass äh die meisten,
Also immer mehr Leute von äh von Hong Kong erzählen, dass das Geile ist, dass in der Nähe ist. Ich fand, ich persönlich fand Hong Kong cooler, weil das also Shingin schon sehr, also man sieht, dass das Ding da halt aufm,
Blatt Papier entworfen äh und äh hingezogen wurde. Ne, also ähm.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz, also hat einen gewissen Weib, also halt die die der Puls, der die Geschwindigkeit und auch der Enthusiasmus, mit dem Leute in Shinchan.
Leben und arbeiten, ist halt auch schon faszinierend, also für Freunde von mir wohnen da auch schon seit immer, sehr Englischlehrer und so und das ist auch schon cool,
Das Wichtige an ist halt, weil's halt so rapide wächst, also geometrisch wächst, ist es halt so, da kommen dann Leute aus ganz China, ziehen da hin,
um ihr Glück zu machen. Um halt irgendwie vom Kaff irgendwie vom Land chroral Verhältnisse oder so in die Stadt zu ziehen, weil sie halt da irgendwie in der Fabriken Arbeit äh an Arbeit finden dann.
Das passiert halt in gerade, also seit seit zwei Jahrzehnten oder so. Und das sind halt alles Leute, die ziehen dann dahin.
Ohne ihre Familie, ohne ihre traditionellen Backgrounds und so. Das heißt, sie erfinden dann grade so eine sehr spezielle eigene Kultur miteinander,
untereinander gegenseitig. Ne, das passiert halt alles gerade so sehr, sehr organisch, dass ich da was ganz Neues rausbildet, weil halt ansonsten Kultur eher traditionell und halt eher konfuzianisch halt,
halt so haben wir das schon immer gemacht und so weiter und von oben runter, also halt nicht das Politische, sondern das
halt anders funktioniert. Aber wenn auf einmal dann so viele junge Leute dann da auf einmal äh zusammenkommen, ne und dann halt,
ihre Sexualität und ihre Interessen und ihre Vollliebe für Musik und Tanz und so. Ich meine, das gibt's ja schon alles schon. Ist komplett anders, als hier ist komplett anders als ein Hong, aber als in Hong Kong, aber da passiert schon viel. Das ist jetzt nicht nur die Elektronik Stores, die das, die das interessant machen.
Und ist auch eine Special Economic Reaching, ne? Also.
Ja. Äh habe nicht ganz verstanden, was das bedeutet. Ich glaube, das ist eher interessant für, ob man als chinesischer äh Staatsbürger da.
Wie einfach so ist, da eine Firma aufzubauen und welche Regulaturen, Regulatorien der berücksichtigen muss. Ähm,
Wie du gesagt hast, es gibt auch ein bisschen anderes Visa, das ist einfacher für Westleiter, kurz hinzufahren, äh also man muss jetzt nicht zum Konsulat gehen oder so vorher, sondern man kriegt dann für kriegt man Visa auch direkt an der Grenze oder,
je nachdem wie die politische Beziehung grade an dem Wochenende sind, geht das zumindest auf die meiste Zeit. Ähm ja, habe aber schon was anderes als der Rest von China.
Ich glaube, zu meinem Wochenende waren die Beziehungen gerade nicht so gut. Mich haben sie so geärgert. Ähm aber das ist eine andere Geschichte. Ähm,
Okay, jetzt haben wir also ein bisschen über diesen äh Innovationshub da äh,
im an China dran gesprochen, der aber irgendwie trotzdem unter chinesischer Kontrolle steht.
Und jetzt passt das gibt da, du hast gesagt, es gibt einmal dieser CEO muss von der kommunistischen Partei bestätigt werden. Es gibt ein äh,
Über das sich irgendwie China dann doch noch ein bisschen Hoheit hält, aber viele Regeln des Landes treffen jetzt erstmal vor Hong Kong nicht zu.
Seit neunzehnhundertsiebenundneunzig hat Hongkong ähm Basic Law, also halt das keine Konstitution als solches, aber halt ein ein Gesetz,
Buch war Grundgesetzbuch quasi. Ähm wo halt was absolut unabhängig und ganz anders als was in was in China gilt äh aussieht.
Die Tradition der Gerichte, also das englische Commentor ähm der ist der Richter und der der Anwälte und der Staatsanwälte und so weiter, wurde auch mehr oder weniger direkt von,
von der chinesischen äh von der von der Kulinarzeit übernommen. Das heißt, das sind die selben Leute. Das sind dann zur Hälfte chinesische, zur Hälfte, englische oder westliche Menschen, die da halt einen Richter in einen Richter sitzen,
und so ähm uns hat du hast halt die die Rechts,
Sicherheit, das war in der Tat auch so beredet hatten, einer der Gründe, weswegen Hongkong so interessant ist
Wollte da nämlich seinen Vertrags- und Rechtssicherheit hast, die den anderen Ländern in Asien vielleicht in Singapur, ja, aber ansonsten nicht so einfach bekommst, von wegen halt, dass du halt sicher sein kannst, wenn hier irgendjemand mir meinen,
den Vertrag nicht erfüllt, dann kann ich einfach dagegen klagen und dann kriege ich das auch schon noch irgendwie durch und so. Also da gibt's auf jeden Fall äh Methoden, ne, dass äh man kann sich halt auf bestimmte bestimmte Sachen mehr verlassen.
Dass es ein wichtiger Faktor, den hatte ich gar nicht so oft im Schirm. Und der würdest du sagen, das ist im Rest von oder im Rest von China nicht unbedingt so.
Absolut nicht so wie ich das verstanden habe, also von meinen Freunden her, ähm,
ist Korruption und Vetternwirtschaft anscheinend ein deutlich wichtigerer Aspekt in in in der Volksrepublik. Ähm ich bin da kein Experte, ich habe nie länger in in China gewohnt, aber die haben auf jeden Fall nicht,
ein auf dem Englischen System mit irgendwie Richtern in so lustigen Talaren und so, das ist halt ist halt in Hongkong schon noch alles sehr europäisch, also grad die die äh Judikative, äh diese Brunch.
Ja, also ein Kulturschock kriegt man da auf jeden Fall nicht, weil das äh aufgrund der asiatischen äh Komponenten, also klar, man kann einige Schilder nicht lesen,
aber äh so das ist schon für westliche Personen ähm sehr eine sehr erträgliche Stadt,
um da jetzt mal so anzukommen.
Ja, das hat's für mich auch sehr einfach gemacht, ansonsten hätte ich's wahrscheinlich auch net so lange da ausgehalten, dass er.
Also wenn du jetzt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Momby oder so, ist schon ein etwas anderer Schnack, als äh als jetzt äh in.
Klar, also ist auf jeden Fall also mit dem Gehalt, was man da auch als westlicher in irgendwie äh äh kriegt, also,
ähm Praktikant selbst, dann hast du trotzdem noch absolutes First World,
Existenz, also du kriegst halt Internet und heißes Wasser und Strom und alles sauber und du gehst zum Arzt und so und das ist halt alles schon auf einem sehr hohen Niveau. Vielleicht nicht ganz so schön, wie in Singapur nicht ganz so perfekt, aber halt absolut.
Dafür mit Meerschaum.
Absolut.
Und und jetzt hast du ähm äh jetzt hat China also unten an sich dran diesen diese Nabel der Weltsituation, wo die wo westliche Kultur.
Bei ihnen vor der Haustür, unter ihrer eigenen Kontrolle stattfindet,
oder unter ihrer eigenen vermeintlichen Kontrolle stattfindet, ähm wo auch relativ klar ist, dass es also der Kapitalismus da so ungezügelt vor sich hinballert und.
Man irgendwie sieht, okay, wo wo geht, wo geht vielleicht auch die Reise mit der Welt hin.
Ja, je nachdem, wie du das siehst, ne, also wohlgemerkt, ist deutlich kapitalistischer als Hongkong, auch finde ich, gefühlt.
Also Linus, die haben da Elektronikmärkte, in denen die Handypreise, also der Preis für ein iPhone oder Samsung Galaxy auf so eine,
nicht digital, sondern wegwischt Tafel, halb Minutenmäßig aufgemalt wird. Das heißt, weißt du, wenn wenn du
jetzt kaufst, ist es billiger, als wenn du in fünf Minuten erst kaufst. Das ist der Kapitalist Platz, den ich jemals gesehen habe, ist in.
Und halt noch deutlich schneller als in Hong Kong, insofern ist ein bisschen unklar, das was du sagst, steh ich schon mit überein, aber das ist nicht der Kapitalismus, der jetzt
in Hongkong ist und nicht in. Das ist eher halt dieses kulturelle und Leute sagen, was sie meinen und.
Okay, also der Liberalismus ist der Liberalismus ist eher das das Problem, okay. Ähm,
Also jetzt hat jetzt hat China da unten diese liberale Stadt und es ist sogar so, dass sich ja die Honkies, du hast mir gesagt, sie heißen nennen sich Honkeys.
Die Personen, die Native, Hongkong Bewohnerinnen sind, die haben auch nicht unbedingt Bock auf die Chinesinnen.
Nee, das ist äh eine andere Kultur.
Also zum einen ist es so, das muss man vielleicht nochmal dazu sagen, ähm China ist recht großes Land, ähm da wird zumindest seit der kommunistischen Revolution ähm ja.
Bin auch kein geschichtswissenschaftler, wie gesagt, also in China wird in der China wird Mandarinen geredet. Das ist ein anderer dialektisch, chinesische Sprache oder andere Sprache als kantonesisch, kantonesisch ist aber wenn Hongkong mit Hongkong gesprochen, also.
So ähnlich wie was weiß ich, Schwäbisch und Deutsch.
Ne? Ja, nee. Ähm, nee, das muss man sich eher so vorstellen, der Unterschied zwischen Schwitzer, Deutsch und Niederländisch.
Ja, wo es auch so ist, als Mitteldeutscher kann man das auch beides halbwegs verstehen und lesen, aber ich glaube, Holländer und Schweizer ist mehr dabei.
Diese Fremden sind nicht von hier.
Nee, ja, ja, das auf jeden Fall. Uns ist sowas ganz anderes. Ähm genau so in der Schriftsprache ist es so, China ähm China gibt's. Äh das ist von Marok glaube ich. Ähm und dann in in Hongkong äh traditionell traditional Trainees. Das sind halt irgendwie
simple Fighter, vereinfacht das chinesisches Ding wie zweitausend Schriftzeichen und das äh traditionelle sind sechstausend oder so. Das heißt ähm auf dem Level schon unterschiedliche Kultur.
Und ähm auch im sagen wir mal in den äh Ansprüchen an das Leben und auch im Betragen im öffentlichen Raum.
Das ist äh die Meinung von vielen Hongkong. Chinesen auf jeden Fall, dass Hongkong ähm äh zivilisierte und fortschrittlicher ist, dass man da halt nicht auf den Boden sp
und so was und das wird dann den chinesischen Besuchern aus aus dem chinesischen die nach Hong Kong kommen wird das auch gerne vorgeworfen, da gibt's dann auch immer
natürlich auch zeitweise sehr rassistische äh Bemerkungen oder oder äh äh Strömung. Das also Hongkong Leute sehen sich schon, Hongkong Native
Bewohner sehen sich schon anders als Melent äh Volksrepublik, Chinesen.
Finden sie, also die fühlen sich besser.
Also, je nachdem, wie man,
und so. Es gibt natürlich auch viele Leute, die sehr stolz sind, äh Chinesen zu sein, weil natürlich das chinesische Jahrtausend gerade an vorhanden hat und das schon alles sehr spannend ist
was da passiert mit der der Weltraumreisenden und der Technologie und so, also da, das ist, das gilt jetzt nicht für alle, das ist in der Tat auch die Spaltung, die
grad durch die Stadt geht. Ähm aber auf jeden Fall sehen Leute sich als viel, viele, viele, viele Leute sehen sich nicht sehr verbunden mit der Volksrepublik China,
Das fängt schon bei den Toiletten an, die Toiletten sind in China, ich weiß nicht, ob du das gesehen hast, aber eher zum Kauen,
Man hockt sich hin, also es gibt keinen Porzellanthronen, wie man das Europa kennt, sondern man hockt sich hin und hängt sich dann so so rein. Ähm,
und in Hongkong hast du überall,
was man in Europa auch erwarten würde halt äh Wasserspülung äh so ein so ein so ein Sitzhalt, so ein so ein Sessel. Ähm das ist schon, das magst du schon direkt und da würde sich in Hongkong auch niemand richtig wohlfühlen, wenn es auf einmal komplett verändert würde, so wie es ist.
Ein Erdloch äh ersetzt.
Genau, also gibt's halt auch irgendwie schriftlich, aber ich meine, das ist auf jeden Fall solche Details. Merkt man das schon, das hat's dann halt schon. Hundert Jahre, die da andere, andere Kulturprägungen stattgefunden hat.
Und das ist das ist ja nicht so also das ist nicht so einfach,
dass das so etwas einzufangen, ne? Und da das versucht aber China in zunehmendem Maße, Hongkong.
Dafür zu sorgen, dass ihnen Hongkong, ich sage das jetzt mal freundlich, nicht aus dem Ruder läuft.
Nicht entgleitet, ja, so, so, so kann man das sicher sehen. Ähm, gibt's halt.
Und Hongkong hat da keinen Bock drauf. Hongkong ist im Prinzip eine sehr freie Stadt, die ähm.
Und wir haben das jetzt, ich meine, das ist ja auch der Anlass für uns, für unsere Sendung heute. Hm,
Es ist jetzt wahrscheinlich den meisten nicht entgangen, dass es in Hongkong erstens relativ große Sorge gibt, davor, von China irgendwie.
Vereinnahmt oder beschnitten oder eingeschränkt zu werden und ähm das auch schon seit vielen Jahren und gleichzeitig von China auch Bestrebungen genau das zu tun.
Absolut, das äh und das spitzt sich jetzt halt gerade zu. Das ist auch alles nichts Neues, das braucht er sich da gewohnt habe, noch der Fall. Aber hat sich in den letzten zehn Jahren dann nochmal beschleunigt und ist halt auch alles noch mal ein bisschen hässlicher und konkreter geworden.
Was hast du denn, du hast gesagt, du hast das äh also auch in den letzten zehn Jahren so ein bisschen mitbekommen. Wir haben jetzt, also ich meine, die die wichtigen,
Eckpunkte sind, die so zwanzig vierzehn am Breather-Revolution, da ging's ja schon mal so richtig rund und dann zwanzig neunzehn jetzt die Auseinandersetzung,
was waren denn die Auseinandersetzungen oder die politischen Entwicklungen, die zu diesem.
Die zwanzig vierzehn zu den ersten großen international wahrgenommenen Protesten führten.
Zwanzig vierzehn,
also bei sowas natürlich immer verschiedene Faktoren, die werden da zusammenkommen und so, aber eine der wichtigsten Aspekte war, dass ähm die ähm Regierung, wie gesagt, die dann von Tschechien schon eingesetzt oder zumindest äh ähm äh,
äh erlassene äh Regierung von von Hongkong die Gesetze dahingehend geändert hat, äh dass der,
das Staatsoberhaupt, also der Chief Executive Officer von von Hong Kong, ähm.
Eben von der von der äh Volksrepublik eingesetzt, also er filmt, also beglaubigt ähm.
Bestätigt, bestätigt werden muss. Ähm das war vorher nicht so, das vorher war das anscheinend äh noch nicht der Fall.
Der andere große Aspekt war, dass ähm Chinesisch die, wie gesagt, Mandarinenchinesisch, was in der Volksrepublik gesprochen wird, äh als äh
also äh äh in Schulkorriculum vorgeschrieben wurde, das heißt, dass da ebenfalls dann Kinder auf einmal,
Die Muttersprache von Schienen erlernen müssen neben dem normalen Chinesisch, was mein Hongkong spricht.
Man merkt, dass du jetzt äh in deiner Erinnerung äh in einer anderen Sprache bist mit äh Menitori, also eine äh.
Ich unterhalte mich sehr selten auf Deutsch über diese ganze Thematik, das macht's alles kompliziert.
Nee, finde ich, äh finde ich ja auch äh gar nicht so verkehrt da einfach, weil die richtigen Begriffe, äh die dort auch verwendet werden, zu nutzen. Dafür haben wir ja dafür gesorgt, dass sehr viel Englisch in Hongkong gesprochen,
haben die Briten ja für uns damals äh so gemacht. Also Mandarin, die Sprache, die eigentlich keiner in Hongkong spricht,
wird jetzt in der Schule verpflichtend,
Klar, ne, also aus Chinas Sicht macht das natürlich Sinn, um dafür zu sorgen, dass eben na diese ähm diese kulturelle Aufzusplittung durch die andere Sprache nicht zu groß wird,
Nicht, dass sie nachher mit ihrer eigenen Sprache da abdampfen, das wollen wir nicht, ne? Das und,
ähm das Staatsoberhaupt zu kontrollieren, ist auch immer eine ganz gute Möglichkeit.
Aber das waren halt beides noch so Sachen, die so ein bisschen so eher so ein langfristiges Planen, ne, von wegen so, wir machen das jetzt und dann in zwei Generationen dann dann wird sich diese, diese Strategie ähm wird Früchte tragen, ähm
aber da hatten natürlich Leute in Hong Kong keine Lust drauf, also spezifisch die Studenten und Schüler hatten da überhaupt keinen Bock drauf. Äh und deswegen kam's dann zweitausendvierzehn zu der Amped Revolution
beziehungsweise äh das war klasse. Äh man muss da vielleicht dazu sagen, dass meine Wahrnehmung von Hongkong immer war,
das ist alles sehr politisch und es geht halt hauptsächlich ums Arbeiten und Geld verdienen und einkaufen gehen und so richtig los, also so viel, also,
so wie man das irgendwie aus Berlin oder Frankfurt kennt oder so, ist das so. Also ganz anders da. Ähm,
wurde ich dann deutlich schnell eines Besseren belehrt, zwanzig vierzehn, weil dann auf einmal wirklich sehr viele Menschen, Studenten
aber auch generell Leute an Alters und aus allen äh aus allen äh Gruppen der Gesellschaft, auf einem auf der Straße zusammenkamen zu riesigen Protesten, Sit-ins, alles super friedlich und super schön.
Und Millionen von Menschen, ne, also die größten Proteste.
Groß die, die großen äh Protest, also Märsche, wo man dann bis zu einer Million, das ist ja immer wie man fragt, die Bullen haben natürlich weniger, die Polizei ändert sich weniger gesagt und ähm die die offiziellen Veranstalter dann so eine Million. Ähm,
aber das eigentliche Sit-in, also was dann hauptsächlich auch von Studenten oder von jungen Leuten hauptsächlich gemacht war, wo man wirklich sich vorstellen muss, dass halt diese Straßen, die du gesehen hast,
Normal halt normalerweise da irgendwie mit dem Taxi durchfährt, ähm halt wirklich.
Weiß ich nicht wie viel Spuren. Acht Spuren.
Vier mal zwei Spuren dann wirklich halt.
Zwei mal vier Spuren. Viermal zwei wäre auch lustig, aber echt riskant.
Ja ja, so meinte ich das. Ähm.
Die wandern zu, da haben halt Leute dann monatelang, nicht immer dieselben, aber halt da, das war halt voller Menschen, die da gesessen haben, teilweise gezeltet haben und halt einfach nur friedlich einfach, dass,
Ähm der Name war Programm, das halt wirklich da einfach zugemacht haben. Ähm hat natürlich auch gesungen und und ähm Proteste,
Plakate hochgehalten.
Haben diese, die haben diese Straßen über mehrere Tage besetzt oder jeden Tag aufs Neue.
Nein, das war, das wurde gehalten, also wenn man jetzt taktisch das äh beschreiben will, wurde das monatelang,
gehalten von der Protestbewegung, da waren Iglu-Zelte und halt halbwegs feste Strukturen, also jetzt Bambusstangen zusammengezimmerte, vielleicht so eine kleine Bühne oder halt irgendwie so kleine,
dass man irgendwie über den Mittelstreifen drüber konnte und so, aber das war halt monatelang,
sind da keine Busse gefahren und keine Taxis und das ist halt wirklich die Straße, die man langfahren muss, wenn man irgendwie halt,
zur Bank of China will oder muss oder so, das war halt also der Hauptknotenpunkt.
War halt war halt nichts, da da war halt äh war halt Protest.
Wow, also der äh mehrere, also mehrere Wochen, weil das ja.
Das war irgendwie
von von Juni bis zum November. Das ist dann irgendwann ausgelaufen im November. Ähm wie gesagt, das war halt generell hatten die Leute halt keine Lust auf diese Änderung des Curriculums und auf die Änderung, dass das Wahlrecht für für den äh CEO ähm hatten aber nicht so,
Forderungen, dass äh auf jeden Fall nicht welche, die so einfach durchzusetzen waren. Ähm und generell wollten wir, also,
Mir kam's persönlich auch so vor, dass generell Leute auch sehr viel Spaß dran hatten da einfach äh halt sich so so ein bisschen zu benehmen, wie sie wollen dann halt ihre ihre äh,
ihre Freiheit, ihre äh ihre Meinung ausleben zu können. Ähm sofern ist das so ein bisschen einfach.
Mal keine zielgerichtete Demonstration für oder gegen irgendwas sehr spezielles, sondern es war einfach mehr so ein Ausdruck von.
Wir finden das alles, wie es im Augenblick läuft, net so geil, aber jetzt hier auf der Straße irgendwie zu zelten und zu wohnen und uns gegenseitig Mut zu machen und Sachen beizubringen, finden wir sehr geil,
und deshalb hat er einfach monatelang so stattgefunden und das war schon erstaunlich, das war schon ein sehr ein Ausnahmezustand.
Und äh vielleicht sollte man noch ein bisschen, äh warum haben die die ähm Regenschirme gehabt?
Weil die Polizei natürlich mit Tränengas äh versucht hat, das am Anfang aufzulösen und immer wieder versucht, also
halt taktisch vorgegangen ist und versucht da Menschenversammlungen sind ja generell erlaubt, aber muss es auch vorher anmelden und wenn die Polizei sagt, jetzt weggehen, dann muss er uns da normalerweise auch Folge leisten, ähm Regenschirme waren da äh am Anfang nur ein taktisches
also in Hongkong ging das zu Deutschland, in Hongkong und in England hat man halt einen Regenschirm dabei wenn's regnet, ne?
Das ist da einfach auch ein normales äh normales Alltagsgegenstand. Den hatten Leute dann auch dabei und ereignet sich halt auch sehr gut um gegen äh Polizeigewalt spezifisch, Tränengas,
hat natürlich auch Knüppel und sofort zu gehen äh und hat sich dann auch als Symbol.
Sichtschutz äh sieht man die ja dann auch manchmal, ne? Das ist irgendwie quasi wenn irgendwo Leute was vorbereiten, äh dass dann sich andere drum herumstellen, alle ihre Regenschirme aufspannen. Äh.
Taktiken auf einmal so eine Schildkröte aus Regenschirm irgendwo auftaucht und so ein bisschen unklar, was da drunter passiert, ja.
Muss ich das vorstellen? Das sieht aus wie die Römer äh bei.
Genau.
Ja also war Wahnsinn, ne, diese äh was die an Protest Techniken, Taktiken ähm entwickelt haben.
Und das war das wirklich lustige dran, dass das halt damals das gab's vorher nicht in Hong Kong. Das hat auch niemand denen so beigebracht. Das wurde halt alles sich so,
pragmatisch irgendwie vor Ort und dann wirst du zu dem Zeitpunkt irgendwie halt,
Also zusammengefunden und, und, und, und entwickelt. Das war das wirklich lustige Trend. Also ich würde mal sagen, in Deutschland zumindest Westdeutschland gibt's eine gewisse Protestkultur
ja, Demokultur, da gibt's auch bestimmte Gruppierungen, die das mehr oder weniger organisiert durch betreiben, aber mal generell weiß man schon, wie man sowas macht und nicht macht.
Rituale.
Genau, genau. Und wohlgemerkt die ähm die äh Polizei kennt die Rituale auch. Die haben ihre eigenen Rituale, die kennen auch die Demonstranten Rituale, die haben auch ihre eigenen Taktiken und so. Die Hongkong Polizei hatte da auch keine Ahnung,
Also ich mein, die wussten auch nicht, wie sie jetzt da vorgehen konnten. Die konnten ja keine letale tödliche Gewalt einsetzen. Das äh,
zumindest politisch nicht gewollt und nicht aufm Plan zweitausendvierzehn. Ähm aber was man jetzt da, wie man das dann halt macht, also
wohlgemerkt, wie gesagt, Honko, auch alle Leute mit Telefon, Mobiltelefon unterwegs, überall Empfang. Da war dann halt auch alles, immer wenn irgendwie irgendwo Polizei aufgetaucht ist, immer gleich alle Leute mit Telefon dabei und gefilmt.
Konnte es dann auch einfach hochstreamen und so, ne? Das ist ja halt alles das Internet ist ja direkt immer bei dir. Das heißt, dass du.
War taktisch eine Challenge für die Polizei, da jetzt auch wirklich ihre ihre ähm ihre äh Befehle auszuführen, beziehungsweise weiß man wegen Straße freimachen oder so, das wussten die nicht ganz, wie sie das machen sollen,
Und das war das interessante dran, deswegen hat das auch so ein Sommer lang echt alles sehr, war sehr interessant.
Das klingt äh klingt enorm spannend. Und das war jetzt, also das ist alles zwanzig vierzehn, aber.
Zwotausendvierzehn, das ist dann prinzipiell und natürlich dann gibt's nebenher natürlich auch den politischen Konkurs in der
Diskurs in der Gesellschaft, ne, wo Leute sich dann dafür in der Gegend ausbrechen und Familien zerstreiten und halt das in allen möglichsten Medien und und äh als Thema durch durchkommt. Ähm da war auch die Stadt dann schon,
Da habe ich so ein bisschen gespalten, also das war jetzt, ich habe hauptsächlich die Proteste kennengelernt, da gab's natürlich auch viele Leute, die dagegen waren, äh dass sie vielleicht äh Rechts und Ordnung auch wichtiger finden oder generell vielleicht auch China, wichtiger oder cooler finden als Hongkong. Ähm,
Das hat man dann auch wirklich gesehen, also auf Facebook, das war damals noch sehr wichtig in Hongkong, ähm war das dann auch so, dass entweder so ein Yellow ribben, also wie diese.
AntiHIV, also HIV-Aufmerksamkeitsrims, diese diese Bändchen, die, die, die man kennt, die Roten.
H Schleifer, glaube ich, genannt oder so. Na also die rote einmal.
Genau. Und die gab's dann einmal in gelb für die Protestanten. Äh die Demonstranten,
Protestanten zu tun. Für die Demosrenten, dann äh in gelb. Und dann die äh die reaktionäre äh Partei dann auf in blau, äh hatten das dann einfach als Facebook-Symbol sehr häufig und hat dann wirklich gesehen, dass die Stadt so blau gegen gelb irgendwie sich hier gerade.
Das Blau steht für.
Ich hab's nicht ganz verstanden, Polizei im Generellen, das waren dann schon Leute, die sich hauptsächlich für um die Sicherheit der der äh.
Und und gelb steht für, also die haben einfach die Farbe.
Habe ich auch nicht ganz verstanden dabei, Farben sind kulturell spezifisch, also in China was anderes als hier, gelb
halt, ja, keine Ahnung. Da muss man andere Leute fragen, ähm aber generell gab's halt dann diese diese Aufteilung so ein bisschen, man hat das dann auch schon gemerkt und da gab's dann auch wirklich halt schon auch dieses,
bestimmte Restaurants geht man halt nicht hin, weil man nicht derselben
Ist wieder für Restaurantbesitzer, also bestimmte Leute haben sich dann schon auch entsprechend positioniert. Also hauptsächlich in Online-Medien dann halt gesagt, hier wir finden das scheiße oder wir finden das geil und je nachdem. Also hört so ein bisschen Lager Lagebildung hat er zwotausendvierzehn auch schon stattgefunden,
Aber schlussendlich ist es dann alles mehr oder weniger, weil die Polizei halt nicht wusste, wie man damit umgehen soll. Ne, also die wussten halt auch nicht, dass man jetzt hier einfach.
Ein paar Leute sich als Demonstranten anziehen sollten und da gar hingehen und mal irgendwie,
Gewalt anwenden und anfangen sollten und dann gibt's eine gute Ausrede, da drauf zu hauen, das das,
Genau, das war alles neu. Da hatten sie auch noch keine Wasserwerfer gehabt. Da gab's halt noch nicht in der Stadt, insofern war's halt taktisch nicht möglich, das aufzulösen und die Studenten, die die Demonstranten sind auch irgendwann so ein bisschen, weil sie halt keine richtigen Forderungen hatten,
Ist ja auch so ein bisschen einfach dann gegen Weihnachten einfach auch so äh äh der Dampf nachgelassen, äh waren ja Autos, die insofern ist das alles so ein bisschen einfach so im Sande verflossen dann Ende zweitausendvierzehn und dann war auch erstmal wieder Ruhe.
Aber die einfache Forderung macht diese beiden ähm.
Diese beiden Entscheidungen rückgängig, auch die konnten sie nicht durchsetzen, ne. Also die äh das mit dem Mandarinenlernen in der Schule ist geblieben und auch die Bestätigung des, der CEO ist geblieben.
Habe ich so verstanden, das war nicht durchzusetzen, wohlgemerkt hat die Hongkong Regierung da auch keine Handlungsfreiheit, weil die ja ebenfalls von der chinesischen Regierung,
weisungsweisung bekommt. Insofern hatten die auch wirklich ja da, da konnten sie eigentlich nicht viel machen.
Das heißt, die Konsequenz ist, ähm China lernt OO. Wir brauchen auf jeden Fall mal ein paar Wasserwerfer und ein bisschen taktisches Training.
Also Hongkong, Hongkong selber hat es dann gelernt und haben sich da dann weitergebildet, ja. Vermutlich auch im westlichen,
später einkaufen gegangen, haben dann erstmal ihre Leute auf Fortbildung geschickt
äh wahrscheinlich auf der äh auf der Demonstrantenseite ist so was ähnliches passiert. Da haben sich Leute auch radikalisiert und polituritisiert. Ähm insofern,
zwotausendfünfzehn, zweitausendsechzehn, ähm war erstmal Ruhe und jetzt zwotausendneunzehn, weswegen wir davon reden wollen. Ähm,
Es ist dann halt wieder aufgekocht alles, hauptsächlich wegen diesem ähm extrodition, also dem Auslieferungs, der Änderung, des Auslieferungs äh Gesetzes in Hongkong.
Und die Situation war nämlich so, dass Hongkong trotz aller Kontrolle Chinas nicht notwendigerweise ausliefert an Mailand Shiner.
Beziehungsweise generell nicht ausliefert an Ländern, mit denen keine direkten äh bilateralen Auslieferungsverfahren bestehen. Der Aufhänger,
vermeintlich, also der mit dem das
begründet wurde, war ein Fall den Taiwan äh und das war natürlich alles noch mal sehr kompliziert, weil wenn man das Taiwan noch nicht mal als Land ansieht, dann ist es auch unklar, ob man da einen bilateralen Vertrag machen kann, aber generell ähm wurde dann also ein Gesetzes äh,
Vorschlag eingebracht, ähm der halt die Auslieferung in,
Staaten, mit denen kein Ausregungsverfahren äh Abkommen äh besteht, erlaubt hat, unter bestimmten irgendwie dann der der Regierungschef muss das halt irgendwie nochmal abzeichnen oder so, also da gab's halt so ein paar irgendwie, also es gibt halt gab's halt so eine so eine Funktion,
Verfahren, mit dem man das äh äh das Verhältnis funktionieren können, hätte dann gemacht werden würde. Ähm,
aber die Leute hatten halt Angst davor, dass das halt die Auslieferung hauptsächlich nach Main and China ähm.
Ermöglichen würde. Und dazu muss man sagen, dass in diesem Jahr der Ruhe zwischen zwotausendvierzehn, zweitausendneunzehn dann schon immer so Geschichten kamen, dass irgendwelche Buchhändler in Hongkong, irgendwelche Leute, die Bücher,
betreiben oder für die Arbeiten in Hongkong dann auf einmal irgendwie verschwunden sind,
und dann in China wieder aufgetaucht sind oder irgendwie wieder zurück waren und sagen, das war jetzt in der Freiwilligen gegangen, es war alles sehr, sehr unklar, aber man hatte generell das Gefühl, dass äh Leute durchaus nach China ausgeliefert werden, auch ohne.
Grundlage davon oder so, also prinzipiell die also, wenn man als Hongkong Aktivist politisch irgendwie auffällig war, hatte man schon Angst davor, auf einmal,
sich entschieden, er wieder zu finden, also im hinten in irgend 'n Bus drin zu liegen, dann über die Grenze gefahren zu werden oder ich.
Mal kurz rüberkommt.
Sowas. Weißt du, Licht um die Ecke und so, ne und äh was immer, Flugzeug oder oder oder ähm oder Boot. Ähm und dann ist halt sofort was anderes, weil dann halt diese ganze äh Tradition von von Richtern und Anwälten und Staatsanwälten dann halt eben,
was ganz anderes, also die die ist dann halt weg. Insofern hatten Leute dann halt Angst und zwotausend Anfang äh letzten Jahres,
Ähm das ist jetzt halt alles nochmal einfach äh gestreamt wird und vereinfacht wird, um halt,
Menschen, denen man in Hongkong jetzt vielleicht nicht ohne weiteres irgendwie ein Prozess machen kann, wegen irgendwelchen Verleumdungen oder was immer, ja.
Und ja, das sollten wir vielleicht nochmal betonen. Also es geht ja hier jetzt dann nicht um irgendwie äh was weiß ich, Mord oder Sonstiges, sondern um dann doch relativ ähm,
sagen wir mal, vergehen die in Demokratien in der Regel einfach keine sind.
Je nachdem, was so wie gesagt dieser Aufhängerfall war in der Tat ein Mord, wo irgendwie ein Hongkong.
Einwohner mit seiner Freundin nach Taiwan gefahren ist und hat die dann da umgebracht und dann ist dann aber zurück nach Hongkong geflogen und durfte nicht nach Taiwan ausgeliefert werden, so was. Also generell, aber wo die Leute Angst vor hatten, war halt natürlich,
Sachen, die in Hongkong legal sind, in China aber illegal sind, dann halt,
sich da, wenn man das in Hongkong sagt oder schreibt, sich dann trotzdem in China dafür verantworten zu müssen. Das war, das war die Angst.
Und ich weiß nicht,
sowohl jetzt bei dem neuen Sicherheitsgesetz über das Vergleich noch sprechen, als auch jetzt bei diesem höre es, dass da immer,
Also es gibt dann immer Angst, dass dieses Gesetz bedeuten könnte. Häufig sind aber doch Gesetze eigentlich schon relativ klar geschrieben. Also das das finde ich.
Das Gesetz war, wie ich das verstanden habe, so geschrieben, dass es halt mehr oder weniger äh äh der der ein oder so die Interpretationshoheit, der
Exekutive unterliegt, um dann zu sagen, ja, diesem Auslieferungsantrag wird stattgegeben oder nicht,
Insofern, da war das schon genug Gummi und genug Spiel drin, als dass das. Also, was ja nicht drum geht, von wegen, was ja nicht Teil unseres Gesetze,
in Hongkong, weil wenn Hongkong Gesetzbriester, bist du in Hongkong, vorm Richter, aber wenn du ein Gesetz brichst, was anderes startet dich gerne für für verantwortlich machen würde, dann,
Also so funktionieren ja Auslieferungsverträge generell. Erinnert das an.
Aber das werden in man in vielen Ländern halt irgendwie solche einfache Regeln für Auslieferungen hat, wie was weiß ich, das vergehen muss, auch bei uns strafbar sein,
und das Land darf keine Todesstrafe haben und so weiter, dann liefern wir, was weiß ich, an folgende Länder aus
äh war das hier offenbar nicht in dieser Granularität.
Also solche solche Ausschlusskriterien gab's soweit ich es verstanden habe zumindest nicht.
Und damit beginnen im Juni, Juli ungefähr um diese Zeit. Ja. Zwanzig neunzehn in Hongkong wieder Proteste.
Genau, also wie gesagt, auch da wieder halt nicht der einzige Grund, um das halt generell war halt das halt das, also zwanzig vierzehn hat sich ja auch nichts geändert gehabt, insofern generell äh Leute mit mit Sorge, berechtigter Sorge, ähm die dann eben weiterhin,
äh äh Sachen verändert sehen wollten. Und das sind dann halt,
immer an Sonntagen, weil da hat man dann halt auch frei, ähm mehr und mehr Leute auf die Straße gegangen, zu riesigen, friedlichen Protesten, hunderttausend von Leute, die an bis zu Millionen Stärke auch wieder ähm.
Das wurde dann erstmal, also die großen Proteste waren schon alle friedlich. Also eine Million Leute haben da jetzt nicht randaliert oder so,
die wundern aber dann im Gegensatz zu zwanzig vierzehn dann auch immer wieder, die hatten dann so eine Charakteristik, dass dann halt nach dem
großen Protest, der tagsüber bei Sonnenlicht irgendwie stattfindet und wo Leute singen und
Plakate tragen, dass dann durchaus noch ein radikalerer Teil äh zumindest Gewalt gegen Sachen oder Immobilien, ja, also Graffiti und sowas ähm äh,
so was dann abends dann dann auch stattfindet. Und dann kommen da auch diese ähm also da das kennt man dann, das da fangen dann diese diese Bilder an, die man die man kennt mit Leuten halte, mit Gasmasken und
Sonnenbrillen diese spezifische Hongkong Proteste Ästhetik also da da kam dann.
Gewisse Frustration äh auf Seiten der Demonstranten dann zum zum Vorschein. Und es hat sich dann so ein bisschen hochgespiegelt. Also die Polizei hat da wohlgemerkt dann auch sehr schnell immer sehr sehr hart reagiert. Zu dem Zeitpunkt hatten sie dann auch bessere Taktik und,
auch diese Babygans, also diese diese Plastik,
Kugelpistolen, dann zählt sehr großflächig eingesetzt, also sehr sehr liberal eingesetzt. Insofern, da haben sich dann gab's dann immer, also,
hauptsächlich hat einfach die Polizei Platzräumen und die Leute wollen's nicht geräumt, bleiben einfach da und dann versuchen sie halt irgendwie mit Gewalt. Ähm das hat sich dann irgendwie so so hochge,
äh geschaukelt. Ähm das erste wichtige Datum wäre dann der siebte Juli, weil da dann, das kann man vielleicht im Fernsehen gesehen. Ähm die der Legende, also das Parlament in Hongkong, ähm,
gestimmt wurde von Protestanten, das dann auf einmal halt irgendwie keine Sicherheit und irgendwie die Türen dann waren auch auf und so und dann auf einmal halt lauter Leute in diesem sehr Styling. Ähm,
Randalierer-Outfit, dann auf einmal im Parlament irgendwie rumgesprayt haben und so. Ähm das war schon erstaunlich.
Ähm wird der stylische Randalierer-Outfit ist eine sonst schwarz gekleidet, Regenschirm.
Auf jeden Fall, das hat auch ein gewisses Symbolik, ähm Regenschirm, gute Sache praktisch und.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt auch absolutes Symbol, Symbolcharakter, dann die Peter Maske, je nachdem wie gut aber halt am besten halt so eine so eine äh Streichermale und Lackierermaske, äh die dann halt auch die Augen
die Augen schützt vor dem Tränengas. Handschuhe natürlich, festes Schuhwerk.
Und damit sind die in rein.
Da gibt's auch wirklich schön, ich weiß nicht, ob man, ich habe das nicht in deutschen Medien verfolgt, aber da gibt's extrem viele interessante Videos auf, auf YouTube und Twitter, dass äh.
Wie lange sind sie da geblieben.
Also das war ein ein Abend lang, also irgendwie halt aus irgendwelchen Gründen, entweder versagen oder oder äh geplante geplante Manipulationen, aber irgendwie war da, war da keine Sicherheit. Also Gebäudesicherheit oder so.
Und da hat die Polizei auch erstmal nichts gemacht und dann haben die da ziemlich, ja das alles äh mit ihren eigenen Parolen Forderungen versehen von innen.
Später ist es doch auch noch mal in der Pale Euro passiert.
Das ist dann am Ende des, am Ende des, das Jahres, ja. Ähm aber wir können ja mal kurz die das das so ein bisschen die die durchgehen. Ähm
Ist auch schön, dass wir den Podcast heute machen. Linus, der einundzwanzigste Juli ist ein äh spezielles Datum, weil das dann der
Äh der erste Jahrestag heute auch ist äh der Jüng Long äh Attacken durch die Triaden äh in der in der MTR in Hongkong. Ähm war halt auch wieder, wie gesagt, das ist auch alles immer sonntags, weil Sonntags halt Leute,
Zeit haben,
entsprechend viele entkommen. Äh das war halt so, Leute kommen von von ihrem friedlichen Protesten. Demonstrationen ähm auf Hongkong Island zurück, fahren nach. Das ist halt,
ziemlich weit nördlich, ziemlich nah an, also direkt an der Grenze von Cent und eher halt ähm ja nicht nicht ganz so großer Wohlstand und halt eher alles sehr.
Bisschen, bisschen, bisschen andere, andere äh ökonomische, äh andere, andere Klage. Also da generell, ja, dazu sind halt keine Bestleim mehr, die da wohnen, das ist was anderes, als was kennt. Das war dann halt so. Die fanden da.
Leute fahren mit der U-Bahn heim und auf einmal kommen lauter,
Schläger in weißen Unterhemden mit Bambusstöcken in die U-Bahn gerannt und verprügeln da los. Die ganzen Passagiere.
Man muss jetzt hier ganz kurz, weil du schon zum zweiten Mal Bambusstücke erwähnst, die in Europa nicht so verbreitet sind, wie in äh in Asien. Das sind nicht irgendwie so ein bisschen Schild, was wir vom Baggerloch kennen, sondern das sind,
Stabile Rohre, die ähm.
Noch ein bisschen flexibel, also es bricht auch nicht, tut aber trotzdem wirklich weh. Das ist auch schon so ein Kampfsportding, also das.
Absolut, also ne, weil du auch gerade gesagt.
Mal hier als so ein Blechrohr nehmen würde.
Draus gebaut, was dir daraus die bauen daraus ähm am am Bau die Gerüste,
wenn wenn jetzt irgendwie, ne, also ein Haus von außen skeptisch braucht, dann wird das halt aus Bambus und mit Seil gemacht. Also das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie so ein bisschen Bambus, sondern das ist eher so,
die die äh die Kategorie Bambus, aus der ihr hier jetzt auch in Europa das ein oder andere Hipster-Fahrrad neu gebaut wird, ne, also das sind.
Yeah, also Rostock oder so, so das ist, glaube ich, die beste,
genau, also das geht überhaupt nicht, also ist halt also und da waren halt auch wirklich dann auf YouTube direkt oder auf Twitter dann halt Videos von verzweifelten Menschen, die halt einfach zusammengeschlagen werden von hunderten von Gangstern in der U-Bahn.
Ohne Polizei,
Da ist niemand irgendwie aufgetaucht. Man muss dazu sagen, das hätten wir vielleicht am Anfang erwähnen sollen. Hongkong ist super friedlich. Da gibt's nie irgendwie öffentliche Schlägerei oder irgendwelche Probleme. Das ist.
Das passiert halt nie. Ist eine sichersten Plätze der Welt. Da kann man einfach betrunken in der Mittel von der Stadt einschlafen und am nächsten Morgen wacht man auf, halt eine Flasche Wasser neben sich stehen. Das ist alles super, super relaxt.
Da passiert sowas nie. Und auf einmal ist es halt so.
So komische Gangster, alle in weißen Unterhemden, richten da halt wirklich so ein Blutbad an, also im Sinne von, Leute werden wirklich hart verprügelt und ja, also,
ist niemand gestorben, aber das das war wirklich, wirklich erschreckend, sowas hatte ich noch nie gesehen, dass es irgendwie in der Emte, also in der in der in der U-Bahn stattfindet äh und wie gesagt, die Polizei war halt nicht da. Die Leute haben die Polizei angerufen, die Polizei ist halt auch nicht gekommen.
Das hat dann irgendwie vierzig Minuten gedauert, bis die Polizei da war. Bis dahin waren die Leute in weißen Unterhemden auch alle wieder weg. Das war alles ähm.
Wie gesagt, auf halt auch zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo Leute von der Demonstration wieder gerade nach Hause gefahren sind, sah das alles für alle Leute sehr danach aus, als hätte da halt eine nicht öffentliche ähm äh Gewalt,
hat trotzdem die Interessen der Regierung durchgesetzt.
Und warum setzen ausgerechnet die Triaden des Regierungsinteresse durch?
Äh das.
Habe ich auch als Westler zu wenig direkten Einblick in in diese Szene rein. Keine Ahnung, ähm es gab dann später Fotos von einem der ähm der äh konservativen,
Politiker, der mit den Trilliarden Leuten gesehen wurde irgendwie. Insofern da gibt's,
zumindest, dass äh dass das halt einfach direkt abgesprochen worden wäre und generell scheint's auch so zu sein, dass das halt auch eine sehr traditionelle und äh äh halbwegs nationalistische,
das organisierte Verbrechen da, also.
Es ja häufig tatsächlich so, dass das organisierte Verbrechen äh besonderes Interesse am Status quo hat, weil die mit dem Status Quo
sich gerade ganz gut arrangiert haben. Und das letzte, was sie äh vielleicht brauchen, ist da nur irgendwie eine Revolution direkt vor der Haustür, ähm die ihnen irgendwie vielleicht die, die traditionellen Geschäftsmodelle irgendwie ins Wanken bringt oder so. Insofern kann ich mir schon vorstellen, klingt aber natürlich enorm.
Wie gesagt, also schwer zu schwer zu sagen, also schlussendlich muss man nochmal weiterverfolgen, sich mit Leuten reden, aber generell. Und das war halt, also es ist schwer zu
beschreiben, was für ein Schock das ist, das zu sehen. Also wenn ich das selber miterlebt hätte, keine Ahnung, das ist
unerwartet. Äh ich meine, wenn ich in Berlin in der S-Bahn bin, dann passe ich schon ein bisschen auf, was für Leute steigen da ein und so, weil es gibt halt schon betrunkene Fußballfans und so weiter. Aber in Hongkong halt nicht. Das ist halt so.
Kannst du einfach mit deinem Kopfhörer auf irgendwie telefonieren, gleichzeitig Musik hören und dein Geld zählen in der Öffentlichkeit und machst überhaupt keine Sorgen um irgendwie, weil das alles ist halt sich super nah, aber das das passiert halt nichts,
Also mir zumindest nicht weit.
Und da gibt's jetzt auf einmal eine Ma.
Und dann halt wirklich so solche Gewaltszenen wohlgemerkt nicht von der Polizei, äh dass das halt ähm das war ein Schock für die für die Stadt als solche. Und wie gesagt, deswegen heute erste erste Jahrestag, die Jahrestage,
kommen jetzt auch in den nächsten Monaten immer immer weiter. Ähm das ist dann auch sieben einundzwanzig, sieht man manchmal. Das ist halt der
einundzwanzigste. Ähm Juli ist halt auch als als Symbol, also seven twenty one, das sieht man sehr häufig gesprüht oder auf irgendwelchen Flyern und und Postern und so. Das hat hat äh dieses Signifikanz
ähm das nächste war dann Ende August acht drei eins, einunddreißigster August ähm hat die Polizei dann in einer U-Bahn-Station, Prinz Edward,
in, aber.
Durchaus nah an Hong Kong Island dran und durchaus halt mitten in der Stadt, wo auch einfach nur alle Leute einkaufen gehen und halt so ganz normales Leben stattfindet, dann da auch
ziemlich willkürlich einfach reingerannt und Leute, also sind wohl irgendwie hinter Demonstranten hergerannt, das war ja so ein bisschen Katze-Maus-Spiel, ähm von wegen,
Demonstranten von der Polizei weg und die Polizei rennt ihnen hinterher und so. Aber an dem Tag ist die Polizei halt irgendwie da einfach in die U-Bahn-Station reingerannt und haben irgendwie alle Leute verprügelt, die so irgendwie aussahen als mit der Demonstration zu tun,
inklusive da Tränengas dann in der U-Bahn Station rumzuschießen, was halt.
Bei der Natur schon sehr, sehr willkürlich natürlich. Ähm alle möglichen Leute äh beeinflusst.
Also jetzt muss man natürlich dazu, warum werden die Leute immer in der MTA angegriffen? Also in der in der oder ist es eine U oder ist eher eine S-Bahn, ne? Von der Größe her würde man das eher S-Bahn ja.
Ja, fährt halt unterirdisch, aber Größe her, eher vergleichbar mit der Ringbahn, ja.
Ähm weil Central ist eigentlich gar nicht so dicht besiedelt oder also ist vielleicht nicht besiedelt, aber so viele Leute wohnen da nicht. Das heißt, die Leute, die da protestieren, die wurden im Zweifelsfall genau nicht in Central, sondern die müssen da wieder.
Wo man den Protest machen will, damit man möglichst viel Weltöffentlichkeit mitbekommt, damit möglichst viele Leute sehen, dass du protestierst, ähm aber da kann sich niemand leisten, zu wohnen, vor allem nicht jemand, der kein Interesse hatte, ähm,
Insofern ja, sind die Leute halt wieder aufm Heimweg da.
Diese diese tausende, hunderttausende bis zu Millionen demonstrierende müssen eigentlich nachher wieder weg und die müssen alle von Central weg und es gibt nur zwei Linien, oder, die da weg oder gibt's nur eine.
Von Hongkong Island gibt's insgesamt drei Linien, die da drei U-Bahnlinien.
Die in Richtung Norden gehen.
Je nach Norden fahren. Ähm das war jetzt wohlgemerkt da nicht meines Verständnisses nach zumindest kein riesiger Protest oder zumindest nicht zum Zeitpunkt, wo jetzt eine Million Leute. Ja. Gleichzeitig irgendwie heimgefahren sind. Also es war jetzt nicht so,
wie man's auch kennt, super Getränk, irgendwie in der S-Bahn, sondern eher so spät abends, dann irgendwie die letzte Schicht Demonstranten, die jetzt grad irgendwie von den, von der Polizei noch wegrennt, ähm du musst ja auch äh U-Bahn fahren, also MTA fahren, das gibt ja, das ist ja.
Wie man sich bewegt in der Stadt, es gibt keine Alter, nicht richtig Alternativen dazu zu öffentlichen Nahverkehr.
Ich wollte nur darauf hinaus, die müssen halt am Ende müssen die da wieder weg.
Können zwar vielleicht den Teil halten, den können dann vielleicht mal eine Straße blockieren oder so, aber die demonstrieren nicht in ihrem in ihrer Heimatumgebung und die müssen halt die müssen abreißen und
das können sie nur mit dem MTA machen und deswegen äh ist das ihr, ist das ihr riskanter Teil, weil sie sich, weil sie da nicht mehr erkennbar sein dürfen, ne? Also ich habe von einigen Leuten auch gehört, dass sie dann zum Beispiel, ne, mit Wechselkleidung,
losgegangen sind, um sich dann halt umzuziehen, um im MTA dann halt nicht mehr wie.
Na ja, das ist absolut absolut sinnvolle, taktisches Verhalten dann halt, diese Standard, wo wir eben beschrieben hatten, ähm die EPD, die äh Protest äh Bekleidung dann halt zu tauschen gegen,
Markenklamotten oder irgendwas, was halt so nachklapping. Ja. Clubbing aussieht irgendwie weiße Jeans, so weiß keine Ahnung. Äh Turnschuhe ähm und wenn man das richtig macht, dann,
das ist halt dann hoffentlich auch so, dass man sich da dann danach äh unbeschwert bewegen kann in der in der Menge,
Wie gesagt, das war dann der Polizei auch egal. Die haben dann halt auch alle möglichen Leute verprügelt, also schwangere Frauen und so, die da überhaupt nichts mit zu tun hatten. Das war einfach nur so ein Mob,
in die U-Bahn-Station rein, schlägt auf Leute rein und ballert halt wohlgemerkt halt auch einfach Tränengas in der ganzen Station rum. Ähm.
Aber glaubst du, das war eine strategische Entscheidung, dass das passiert ist?
Äh auch da wieder schwer zu spekulieren, aber so richtig strategisch, das ist schon alles eher so, also die Polizei hat halt auch wirklich,
teilweise Spaß dran und teilweise halt auch so wenig Erfahrung, dass sie halt einfach nur, also ich weiß es nicht, das kann das kann gezielt irgendwie sein,
das wäre dann ja eine gewisse Terrortaktik, aber ich weiß nicht, ob es das ist, das kann genauso gut auch einfach nur verplant sein, dass halt bestimmte Leute da einfach,
irgendwie über die Stränge schlagen, oder? Muss interpretieren, was sie jetzt machen dürfen oder sollen oder so. Ähm war auf jeden Fall nicht so, dass da irgendwie,
Das sah nicht sehr geordnet aus.
Hat sich da irgendwie mal nachher die Regierung oder Exekutive oder sowas für entschuldigt? Nee, solche Dinge passieren einfach.
Nee, so richtig entschuldigen wird er nicht, dass und das ist auch dann die Korrekturistik der ganzen, des Ganzen letzten Jahres, dass die Polizei eigentlich immer gesagt hat,
aus die Regierung dann immer gesagt hat, wir stehen hinter unserer Polizei und so, dieses Verhalten der Demonstranten ist natürlich gefährlich für die ganze Gesellschaft und muss unterbunden werden und so, also die haben,
nee, da da gab's auch keine internen irgendwie Untersuchungen oder so.
Also da zumindest keine kulturellen Unterschiede zu Deutschland.
Nein, nein, das ist alles. Nein, das ist alles ganz, nein, nein, nein, und auch generell in der westlichen Welt, eine sehr, sehr Standard autoritäre Antwort.
Ja und dann das nächste, das ist das dritte wie ich, also das war jetzt sieben, zwei, eins, acht, drei, eins. Und das dritte wichtige Datum wäre dann eins null eins, der erste Oktober. Ähm,
war dieses letztes Jahr auch der siebzigste Jahrestag der Gründung der Volksrepublik China und insofern äh Leute vorher im Vorfeld schon sehr gespannt ähm was und ob da passieren wird, ja? Ob da
Hongkong Leute noch protestieren dürfen oder bis härter durchgegriffen wird, um da die die Optik der der der Geburtstagsfeier nicht zu versauen. Ähm da gab's dann auch
also hunderttausend von Leuten, die demonstriert haben und dann in der Tat abends dann auch den ersten,
Ich denke nicht Todesfall, wenn ich richtig in Erinnerung habe, aber auf jeden Fall Schusswaffeneinsatz. Also auch im Handgemenge,
und der Polizist der der Demonstrant hat auch durchaus auf den auf den Polizisten.
Der ist auf den Polizisten zugegangen.
Das, das kann man sich auch auf den Videos erkennt man das schon, aber da war halt dann ein Dienstrevolve, der halt wagrecht vorher hatten, so ein paar Mal so Schreckschüsse abgegeben, aber das war halt das erste Mal, dass so ein äh äh Schusswaffe dann auch direkt eingesetzt wurde. Ähm,
und das hat das Ganze halt auch nochmal beschleunigt und radikalisiert.
Bilder sind auch um die Welt gegangen, ne? Da wurde da dann ja also das war, glaube ich, ein Handy-Video oder was man da irgendwie hatte, ne. Es gab auch aus zwei Positionen, glaube ich, wurde es dann nachher.
Da gibt's meistens mehr als eine.
Also eine sagen wir, die Diskussion über diese Situation waren vielfältig. Man kann wahrscheinlich aber zumindest sagen, dass der Polizist nicht in der Situation geschossen hat, in der er,
Maximal bedroht war.
Also wenn man jetzt von der Notwehrhandlung ausgeht, aber gleichzeitig trotzdem unter einer Bedrohungssituation war und ähm das jetzt, also es ist jetzt nicht irgendwie eine eindeutig.
Das war der Polizist jetzt jedes Recht absprechen musste, sich hier eventuell wehren zu müssen.
Nee, das also, wenn ich das richtige Erinnerung habe, ich möchte das jetzt auch nicht im Detail analysieren oder so, aber also die Person selber, der Polizist selber, äh das,
ist natürlich auch schon erschreckend, wenn dann auf einmal Überzahl von Demonstranten irgendwie auf dich zurennt und so, insofern, da würde ich jetzt gar nichts sagen, aber,
Man geht auch nicht mit der Knarre zur Demonstration, das ist eh bescheuert und das ist halt auch, wie gesagt, so ein Schaukeln, ne? Das war dann erster Oktober, das waren halt auch schon nach vier Monaten von jedem Sonntag, also wirklich jeden Sonntag.
Riesen Demonstrationen mit irgendwelchen Schermützeln. Drumrum und wohlgemerkt dann auch an allen Ecken,
der Stadt überall irgendwelche Mannwachen und Leute, die da halt Katzen anzünden und singen und rumstehen und so, also das war den ganzen letzten Sommer, also von Juli an, auf jeden Fall halt wirklich,
jede Woche ein Thema.
Und eine eine Situation, in der jetzt auf einmal sich Hongkong spaltet, in wie du gerade schon sagtest, die Leute, die die Polizei noch mögen und die, die sie nicht mögen,
Ich nehme jetzt mal an, dass es vielleicht vor zwanzig vierzehn ähm oder vielleicht auch vor zwanzig, ja doch vor zwanzig vierzehn keine große.
Keine große, die Polizei keinen so schlechten Ruf hatte.
Nein, die Polizei in Hongkong hat einen hervorragenden Ruf. Das waren also superfreundlich, hilfsbereite. Ja, wie wie man das eigentlich will, halt Menschen, die hier,
nicht durch ihre Präsenz selber einfach Leuten Angst machen oder so auch nicht durch rechten Ordnung sorgen, sondern halt prinzipiell einfach nur da sind, um halt irgendwie, wenn was ist, aber also schwer zu beschreiben.
Also die Polizei die Polizei genießt einen exzellenten Ruf in einer gewaltfreien.
Gewaltfrei bedeutet ja auch, dass die Menschen keiner besonderen Gewalt von der Polizei ausgesetzt sind, die Menschen sich untereinander keiner Gewalt aussetzen. Und jetzt bist du auf einmal in diesem Moment, wo du auf jeden Fall,
von den,
Demonstrierenden, ausgehend Gewalthass, aber natürlich auch von der Polizei ausgehend Gewalt hast und ähm wir wollen, glaube ich, jetzt einfach mal gar kein Urteil über den Einzelfall fällen.
In dem Einzelfall möchte ich nichts dazu sagen. Wie gesagt, als Polizist würde ich mich extrem unwohl fühlen in der Situation. Generell ist es schon so, dass die Demonstranten nicht angefangen haben,
in dem Jahr mit irgendwie, die haben einfach nur, sind einfach nicht weggegangen, wo sie gestanden haben und gesungen haben und die haben halt irgendwie Graffiti geschmiert und und Puste.
Situationen, die wir in im Westen so in den sechziger Jahren hatten.
Oder in Portland halt.
Äh genau und heute ähm also wo natürlich dann kann man jetzt lange drüber diskutieren, weil schon sagen wir mal
ähm konservativ interessierten Menschen wird dann quasi das Versperren des Weges als Gewalt äh wahrgenommen, ne? Und dann sagen die, ja, aber die haben ja, die haben angefangen, äh halten wir einfach mal fest. So.
Man kennt auch die Bilder aus Hongkong, wo dann halt hunderttausend von Leuten,
einfach, also demonstrieren und dann alle Leute zur Seite gehen, damit der Krankenwagen durch kann. Ne, ich meine, das war halt wirklich.
Das ist auch irre.
Cool und friedlich und halt generell halt einfach good vibes und also jetzt, wie gesagt, ist keine wir machen jetzt hier unsere eigene Revolution Rebellion, weil wir Spaß dran haben, Sache, sondern halt wirklich so ein äh.
Das ist ja auch äh will ich jetzt mal vorsichtig sagen, bei jeder Demonstration so, dass die Demonstrierenden sagen so eigentlich soll die Polizei einfach mit bei uns sein.
Ja, das ist von von Nazi bis äh.
Demos haben alle den Anspruch, ey die Polizei kann eigentlich sind wir doch hier die Guten, ne? Okay, also die wir wir buchen die Gewalt eskaliert äh oder erreicht ein ein.
Besonders wahrgenommenen Höhepunkt am am ersten Oktober. Jetzt gab's dieses Problem, dass sich in den in der,
Revolution, äh die hatte keine Forderung, kein Ziel. Daraus hat die Protestbewegung aber jetzt zwanzigneunzehn,
gelernt sie, formuliert nämlich sehr klare Forderungen.
Genau, also eine der Slogans ist dann, also der,
der wichtigste Slogan, ja, fünf eins, das kann man auch mit Emojis machen und so. Fünf Forderungen. Ähm,
am Anfang das Wichtigste war, die Zurücknahme der äh Auslieferung Auslieferungsgesetzes, der Extradidition Bill. Ähm,
dann die äh Zurücknahme der des charakterisierens der Proteste als äh Ausschreitungen. Weil das, wie gesagt, immer die Regierung hat immer gesagt, ja das sind ja auch Ausschreitungen und Anarchie und die brennen hier uns die Stadt ab. Ähm,
die Forderung war, dass das eben als Proteste, als Demonstration, halt als.
Demokratischen Freiheiten äh charakterisiert wird, dass die verhafteten Demonstranten ähm,
viele Leute wurden verhaftet, also,
jedes Wochenende irgendwie Dutzende von Leuten, die dann einfach erstmal in den Glas kamen. Ähm sofern die Forderung ist Amnesty für die für die äh verhafteten Demonstranten, die ansonsten nichts gemacht haben. Ähm und ein eines ähm eine Untersuchung der Polizeigewalt
wie gesagt, auch jedes Wochenende immer mehr zugenommen hat. Also wir haben jetzt nur von den zwei, drei sehr wichtigen Daten geredet, aber das war wirklich jedes Wochenende halt irgendwie
Polizei, die hier Leute rumschubsen, die Leute in wie man das halt auch heutzutage kennt. Alles nichts Neues, typisch autoritäre Taktiken, typisch autoritäres Machogehabe von den, von den Leuten in Uniform. Ähm
wie gesagt, da war die Forderung ähm die die äh Untersuchung, unabhängige Untersuchungen davon und die letzte Forderung dann ähm Universales freies Wahlrecht. Was wie wohlgemerkt auch im ursprünglichen Vertrag zwischen
zwischen England und China so drin stand. Das sind die ähm von denen ist bisher auch nur die Rücknahme des Ausregungsgesetzes.
Erfüllt worden. Die anderen vier Demenz sind nach wie vor offen.
Denn am dreiundzwanzigsten Oktober wurde dann das Auslieferungsgesetz offiziell zurückgezogen. Das war diese Situation ähm.
Schon auf also es ist schon bemerkenswert, ne, also dass irgendwie Carrie Lam musste ja dann einerseits dieses diese,
dieses Gesetz zurückziehen, nachdem das über Monate gefordert wurde von den Protestierenden, die Hongkong ähm ins Chaos gestürzt hatte.
Und gleichzeitig so kein Fehler zugeben. Hat sie wie hat sie das hingekriegt? Nicht so wirklich, ne? Also sie hat.
Nee, das war, das war Gesichtsverlust so oder so, das war aber auch schon vorprogrammiert. Ähm bin mir nicht sicher, was der Richtige die offizielle Begründung dann war, aber prinzipiell haben sie dann einfach eingesehen, dass das so nix wird.
Und ich finde jetzt sehr spannend in den letzten Beschreibungen hier, gerade wenn wir dann so anfangen vorsichtig über Gewalt bei diesen Demonstrationen zu sprechen,
wie wir,
Wir kommen so ein bisschen ins Rudern, ne. Wir wollen jetzt irgendwie, ne, wir wollen jetzt weder sagen, dieser Polizist war ein Mörder, noch wollen wir sagen, die Demonstrierenden haben sich irgendwie
besonders äh waren alle, waren alle frei von vielleicht auch mal einer Gewalttendenz. Aber am Ende reden wir hier von einer,
Metropole, die um Demokratie kämpft und die Forderung sind ja jetzt hier nicht besonders.
Groß, ne, also zu sagen so, wer hier bei diesen Demonstrationen teilgenommen hat, ist ein Demonstrant und kein
Randalierer, wer verhaftet wurde, wird bitte wieder freigelassen. Die Polizeigewalt, die wir hier ausgesetzt wurden, wird bitte bei untersucht, was man ja, also ich meine, das ist natürlich eine unerhörte Forderung, ne? Das kannst du auch in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland nicht machen, ne? Polizeigewalt ist
verboten, also gibt's hier auch nicht, ne, das ist klar. So und also das ist eine das ist unerhörte Forderung, ja? Das muss ich äh wirklich.
Ja, das muss ich sicherlich die schwierigste, das einfache, das Wahlrecht durchzusetzen.
Wahlrecht kann man drüber reden, wobei da kann man sich auch.
Anschauen. Das haben wir in Deutschland auch erst. Ich glaube irgendwie neunzehnhundertsiebenundsiebzig oder sowas. Äh dann mal ist das Wahlrecht gefallen, ja, dann ne, also unerhörte Forderungen hier von Seiten der Demonstrierenden.
Nur um nur um das auch nochmal wieder ins ähm ähm in zumindest zu sagen, dass diese Forderungen hier zu Beginn,
gewisse Selbstverständlichkeiten darstellen, ne? Und auch irgendwie, ne, dieses
Ja, ihr lernt jetzt hier mal eine andere Sprache. Ja, kann man machen, aber es ist also man kann ja gerne in deutschen Schulen ähm französisch als Walfach anbieten. Aber ähm wenn jetzt hier auf einmal
Na also wenn ich.
Thema, aber ja.
Was in Berlin los wäre, wenn jetzt hier.
Ja, so ungefähr rheinlandisch, das kann man sich schon so vorstellen, dass äh das Gabeärger, weil auch alle Leute auf der Straße nee, ich.
Das gibt, das gib Ärger, ja, also der äh das würde, da würde die Berliner Partyszene sich nicht gefallen lassen. Kann man kann man auf jeden Fall so sagen. Hm, ich ich wollte nur nochmal in Erinnerung rufen, dass wir hier ähm.
Also es sind ja basale, demokratische Unabhängigkeiten, die hier.
Absolut, also die, die, die, die, die Sachen, die.
Hier angegriffen werden. Ja, äh die gefordert werden und die hier angegriffen werden. Also das ist jetzt äh und vor allem ist es ja nicht so, was man ja auch äh nicht vergessen darf. Es ist nicht so, dass die Meer fordern, als das, was.
Neunzehnhundert äh was äh zweitausenddrei ganz einfach der Status quo war.
Absolut, also die die radikale Position wäre zu sagen, Unabhängigkeit für Hongkong. Ja, das ist verboten und das ist auch,
für einen Vertrag zwischen England und China verboten. Das ist von China will das nicht äh das wäre radikal. Der wird sich auch nicht irgendwie die Hälfte der Bevölkerung in Hongkong mit anfreunden können. Das wäre halt so die Fahrlift,
Positionen, revolutionäre Positionen, die man einnehmen könnte. Das hat damit nichts zu tun. Ja, drei von den Forderungen sind,
durch die Antwort der Polizei auf die Originalförderung überhaupt,
und nach dem allgemeinen Wahlrecht war halt im Vertrag generell haben wir heute halt so erwartet,
dass man halt wählen kann für seine Volksvertreter und das mit der Exedition Bild war der Grund, weswegen sie eigentlich auf die Straße gegangen sind. Insofern ist das diese fünfte sind eigentlich eher,
Spiegel für die.
Das Unvermögen der Polizei oder der Regierung zu erkennen, was da gerade los ist und da entsprechend drauf zu reagieren. Also auch da die die westliche,
Deutschland zumindest Regierung hat, also die die Autoritäten haben das äh haben das schon ein bisschen besser verstanden, wie man sowas äh zumindest sagt, dass man mal, ne, eine Untersuchung einleitet, ne, oder dann dann sagst du halt, das ist halt
eine Kundgebung und kein gewaltbereit, wenn sie das fordern, ja, das kostet ja nichts, aber die sind halt da, das das war ziemlich tondeff was Carryland da gemacht hat.
So und deswegen muss,
sie auch am dreiundzwanzigsten Oktober dieses Auslieferungsgesetz offiziell zurückziehen und im November wird in Hongkong gewählt. Allerdings nicht,
CEO, die wird ja ohnehin vom von China nochmal bestätigt und glaube, vom überhaupt gewählt?
Äh Novemberwandern der äh Wahlen, also die ähm Bezirks Bezirkswahlen Hongkong hat achtzehn Bezirke. Ähm.
Also Bezirke sind dann so was wie Central, Kallun, hm Moncock, Öl.
Ganz auf dem Plan. Ist lustigerweise dann auch mehr so in dem Ganzen mit drin. Aber prinzipiell halt,
achtzehn Stück. War mehr oder weniger gerecht verteilt auf die auf die Anzahl der Leute, die da wohnen, insofern wird's auch mehr als also Central wohnen nicht so viele Leute, aber
ja ähm hab's nicht ganz auf dem Schirm, äh leider zu der Zeitpunkt auch nicht mehr wahlberechtigt gewesen. Hab's aber trotzdem miterlebt.
Ach du warst sogar wahlberechtigt in Hongkong.
Ich wäre für die District Elections, weil die ja hauptsächlich dann auch so Sachen machen wie ob auf jetzt eine Bibliothek gebaut wird oder,
Starbucks, äh solche solche Entscheidungen. Da werde ich auf jeden Fall wahlberechtigt gewesen für die Letschkow, dann nicht.
Habe ich das richtig verstanden habe, aber wie gesagt, war war leider halt nicht gepasst. Da war ich war ich schon wieder,
mal in Hongkong zu der Zeit, hab's aber mitbekommen. Ähm und das war ganz erstaunlich, weil das halt wirklich so ein Jahr, also nicht aber ein gefühltes halbes Jahr, Monate von jedes Wochenende irgendwie neue,
mehr Leute auf den Straßen und mehr und mehr Politurität von der Polizei weniger Einsicht von der
von der Regierung in was da gerade stattfindet, äh haben sich dann im November in den in den äh in den Ball niedergeschlagen. Da waren dann siebzig Prozent äh der der Wähler waren auch an den Urden. Ansonsten ist das in Hongkong halt,
Hat niemand Zeit für, man geht halt entweder shoppen oder arbeiten, arbeiten, nicht wählen, das ist äh was ich da gewohnt habe, war das, war das eine,
war das nicht wirklich wichtig, aber insofern siebzig Prozent,
der Wähler, die dann auch aufgetaucht sind, war schon bemerkenswert äh und siebzehn von den achtzehn, das trägt von den äh Bezirken, wundern auch von prodemokratischen Parteien. Ähm,
äh genommen. Das heißt, da hat sich einiges verändert in dem in dem District Council. Ähm und war halt als Signal halt auch ein sehr also sehr sehr wichtig und weil danach ist auch erstmal ruhiger geworden auf der Straße. Da hat man generell das Gefühl gehabt, so mit Ende des äh.
Mal gewählt, jetzt haben wir.
Findet halt der Konflikt oder der Diskurs, findet jetzt halt in den, in den äh dafür vorgesehenen Gremien durch Volksvertreter statt. Ähm das das war so ein bisschen die die generelle Stimmung, also da haben Leute dann auch wirklich das, das war alles eine sehr, sehr schöne,
Entspannung, ja? Also ich glaube, dass auch die Polizei oder generell die Leute dagegen sind, sich generell das Gefühl hatten, dass jetzt zumindest die Straßenkämpfe, die Straßenschlachten erstmal vorbei sind. Ähm,
was wichtig war. Ähm gleichzeitig, aber am selben Wochenende oder am Wochenende später oder so,
paar Tage später kam dann auch die Entscheidung in den USA, ähm der der äh Hongkong Human Rights and Domac Democracy Act äh aus dem äh US-Senat oder aus der USA Kammer. Ähm der halt äh.
Bemerkt hat, dass in Hongkong die Demokratie nicht anscheinend genauso wichtig ist, ähm wie wie sie vorher war, also wie man's angenommen hatte. Insofern hat diese,
Humor dann der eingeführt wurde besteht drin, dass halt geschaut einmal im Jahr,
Review gemacht werden muss, ob Hongkong noch diesen demokratischen Grundlagen genügt, die es überhaupt
auf die Basis sind, weswegen diese Exportrestriktion, die Zollrestriktion und Auslieferung und so weiter, diese ganzen Sachen. Deswegen äh Hongkong da anders behandelt wird als China. Das heißt, dass äh seitdem, also Halbzeit, seit November dann halt ein Gesetz in den USA,
Brüste militärische und politische Macht äh neben China. Ähm.
Dann halt das schon als äh Veränderung gesehen haben und dann schon so ein bisschen halt gesagt haben, wir gucken da jetzt drauf und jedes Jahr müsste hier nochmal ne, wer wird da noch weiter gecheckt, ähm wohlgemerkt auch verbunden mit angedrohten Sanktionen gegen äh individuell Vertreter
der Volksrepublik oder von Hongkong, aber das ist ja auch.
Meine Güte, weil äh welche Sanktionen bietet denn die US-Regierung, Individuen auf anderen also äh welche Sanktionen, also Drohungen, weil die weg drohen, also.
Nee. Ähm also in in China nicht, ne. Das äh da wird niemand weggeträumt, nicht nicht aus den USA, in anderen Ländern.
Nee, aber was ist denn eine eine Sanktion gegen.
Terry Lamb hat meines Verständnisses nach die kanadische Staatsbürgerschaft oder zumindest ähm äh permanent Aufenthaltserlaubnis in Kanada. Das ist so, die macht da halt auch also,
Ich habe das so verstanden, als würde nicht irgendwie ihr Leben lang jetzt in Hongkong oder China wohnen müssen, ja? Und das ist auch der Fall für viele andere, also generell.
Ah, okay. Okay, diese Art von Sanktionen, okay.
Genau und oder generell halt viele Leute halt auch gern mal irgendwie nach Florenz oder Mailand fahren, irgendwie auf irgendwelche Modenschauen oder also ich mein's ja nicht so, dass China absolut isolioniert wäre und vor allem die Führungsriege oder halt die TM,
die spezielle Schichte der Leute, die halt ähm ökonomisch und politische Schicht der Leute, die die da Entscheidungen treffen, absolut,
mich begeistert werden von, wie du sagst, Ferraris drin. Und, und, und, und, und, und Handtaschen und und und so was. Was eben nicht aus China kommt,
Ähm insofern ist das schon.
Schlussendlich ein ganz guter Hebel, denke ich, wenn man wenn man sagt, ihr dürft jetzt nicht mehr auf die Moden schauen in Italien, das ist schon das wäre wird Leute schon richtig, richtig treffen, denke ich.
Du bist äh du du darfst nicht mehr den Lifestyle von Louis Vuitton äh äh du bist ein Feind des Lifestyles von Louis Vuitton und deswegen darfst du nicht mehr nach Mailand, hä?
Insofern und das.
Das wäre tatsächlich eine äh.
Also so habe ich das verstanden, also stand auf jeden Fall nicht drin, ähm aber halt, wie gesagt, halt so so ähm permanente Aufenthaltserlaubnisse erziehen oder freie Reisefreiheit,
andere Sachen mit diesen Huwai ähm Vertretern, die also generell das ist also Reisefreiheit ist auf jeden Fall eine der Freiheiten, die man auch als Vereinigte Staaten Leuten wegnehmen kann.
Verstehe, alles reiche. Äh entschuldige die Nachfrage. Also, mir war schon klar, dass hier keine Drohne runterschicken, aber was jetzt eine Sanktion gegen ein Individuum sein könnte.
Muss schon äh mal benannt werden. So, du warst aber zu dieser Zeit zwanzig neunzehn, glaube ich, auch noch mal in Hongkong oder nicht?
Ja, zu der Zeit war ich gerade, also auch weil mich das sehr beunruhigt hat mit den, mit den Nachrichten, den YouTube-Videos, die man die ganze Zeit gesehen hatte, ähm bin ich dann auch immer so
und weil's halt auch recht schön ist im September und Oktober im Vergleich zu Berlin. So, das Wetter ist wirklich, dass äh die
beste Jahreszeit, um dahin zu fahren. Ähm insofern viele, viele Gründe äh war ich aber zu der Zeit dann auch in Hongkong, habe mir das so ein bisschen angeschaut, die Proteste und die ähm,
die Wahlen und so, habe das klappt das dann alles halbwegs direkt mitgekriegt, ja.
Und,
mit diesen Distriktwahlen, die jetzt eigentlich den, den tatsächlichen Konflikt nicht so wirklich betreffen zwischen äh zwischen China und der Hongkong-Bevölkerung
kehrt aber ein bisschen Ruhe ein, der soll mal die das vierte Quartal zwanzig neunzehn verläuft erstmal wieder.
Entspannter, weil man sagt, alles klar, wir haben jetzt hier schön ordentlich pro demokratisch erstmal unsere Distrikt äh Councils besetzt,
ähm.
Expedition Law, das Auslieferungsgesetz wurde auch zurückgezogen. Ähm scheint also erstmal wieder ein bisschen Ruhe im Karton zu.
Also generell hatten die meisten Leute die Hoffnung, dass sie also da zumindest der parlamentarische politische äh Lösung möglich wäre.
Und wie gesagt, das wollte halt auch das war halt auch sehr erschöpfen. Das wollte halt weder die Polizei, noch die Demonstranten, wollten jetzt halt wirklich jeden Sonntag irgendwie sich Straßenkämpfe, Straßenschlachten liefern. Wie gesagt, das ist nicht dasselbe wie
das auch Spaß macht. Ich meine, es gibt so eine bestimmte Phase zwischen,
neunzehnhundertdreiundzwanzig Jahren im Moment Deutschland schon Spaß dran hat, irgendwie demonstrieren zu gehen, hatte ich auf jeden Fall von mir in meinem Freundeskreis so ein bisschen das Gefühl, ähm das ist halt nicht das äh Ding in Hongkong, sondern es Leute sind halt verzweifelt und haben keine Ahnung für was ihre Zukunft.
Und müssen halt was machen.
Was die haben wirklich was, wogegen sie kämpfen.
Und insofern da dann halt, und weil's halt auch taktisch nicht funktioniert gegen die Polizei.
Denn wir haben in der ganzen Schilderung der Situation Hongkongs eine Sache vergessen, nämlich der Status Hong Kongs, die äh der Status den Hongkong jetzt hat, der hat ja auch einen Ablaufdatum.
In der Tat ja zwotausendsiebenundvierzig das hätten wir erwähnen sollen, dass der.
Zwanzig siebenundvierzig des äh genau fünfzig Jahre nach neunzehnhundertsiebenundneunzig endet der jetzt zugesicherte die jetzt noch zugesicherte Situation.
Also das ein Land, zwei Systeme, war in der Tat ebenfalls auf fünfzig Jahre begrenzt vertraglich, also im Sinne von.
Das ist im Vertrag zugesichert, dass es so lang erhalten bleibt und danach ist nichts geplant. Also zwotausendsiebenundvierzig ist ähm so dass die Deadline für bis dahin muss Hongkong irgendwie alles alles geregelt sein. Ansonsten,
Ist es halt, ja. Da da gezogen, kennt Richtlinien mehr.
Und das ist in ja, sechsundzwanzig Jahren. Ja. Das heißt, die jungen Menschen gerade, die eine äh was weiß ich, sagen wir mal, eine Schulbildung abgeschlossen haben in Hongkong,
studieren, die blicken darauf, dass sie so im Prinzip jetzt wissen müssen,
ob sie ob sie was weiß ich, sich in Hongkong überhaupt noch niederlassen können und ein Leben in Freiheit sich hier aufbauen können, weil sechsundzwanzig Jahre scheint lang, wenn du aber eine junge Person bist und,
überlegen musst, wo setze ich hier auf eine Karriere auf auf Freiheit oder sonst was, dann ist das ähm.
Planung, Familienplanung und so ist das halt mittlerweile äh hat der die Deadline so nah, dass muss jetzt halt auch wirklich wissen will und halt auch wirklich in die richtige Richtung gehen will, weil.
Und und vor diesem Hintergrund natürlich auch hier eben die Bestrebungen Chinas dafür zu sorgen, dass das da schön äh ähm eben
zwanzig siebenundvierzig keinen großartigen Aufstand gibt, sondern sich alle darüber einig sind.
Ähm und sich darüber am besten auf Mandarinen einigen.
Ja. Ja, also,
Ich möchte jetzt hier nicht zu viel über die Motivation und die äh inneren Beweggründe der ähm Regierung der Volksrepublik spekulieren, aber soviel sei gesagt, das ist jetzt meines, mein Einschätzung nach nicht ausschließlich nur,
Wir wollen, dass Hongkong China wird, sondern es ist halt auch, wir wollen nicht, dass China Hongkong wird.
Das ist halt, wenn jetzt hier in Hong Kong auf einmal Leute ihr eigenes Ding machen und halt trotzdem noch chinesische Kultur beibehalten und keine Kolonial. Ähm kein mehr sind, sondern halt ihre eigene,
chinesisches Ding machen, aber halt mit Liberalismus und und halt ohne und eine zentralistische, autoritäre Strukturen.
Dann ist das ein ganz unschöner Präzedenzfall, ja.
Genau, genau, genau wie Taiwan, auch so ein ähnliches Problem. Insofern, das ist schon mindestens zwei, zwei äh gliedrige äh Motivationen, die die chinesische Regierung da hat, dass er möglichst alles gleich zu ziehen, Platz zu ziehen, solange das noch geht.
Und äh deswegen hält dieser Frieden auch nicht lange an. Wir sind wir waren jetzt gerade am Ende von.
Zwanzig neunzehn.
Neunzehnten Oktober zwanzig neunzehn. Es gibt irgendwie ein bisschen Ruhe ein, aber.
Und und die generieren, also als als Fazit halt uns, um kurz zusammenzufassen, ist halt so, dass wir halt sechs Monate lang absolutes Chaos, China sahen nicht gut aus. Vor der Weltöffentlichkeit, da war jede, also online schon mal gar nicht,
ähm und auch in in den in den äh klassischen traditionellen Medien
schon immer wieder, irgendwelche Sachen, Videos, also Bilder, die man so nicht sehen will aus seinem eigenen Land. Ähm und das mit der Zurücknahme des eigentlichen Auslösers dann, des Auslösungsgesetzes äh kann man das schon als Versagen,
der Hongkong äh Regierung wahrnehmen, also zu auch von chinesischer Volksrepublik Seite kann man das so wahrnehmen äh und deswegen ist jetzt halt dieses Jahr,
ähm dann die äh dieses äh nationales äh Sicherheitsgesetz angekündigt und dann auch vier Wochen später ähm in Kraft getreten, äh wo dann halt,
prinzipiell die chinesische Regierung gesagt hat, äh das äh das muss jetzt mal anders gehen hier, das ist äh läuft nicht ganz so, wie das laufen soll in China.
Ihr habt den Laden nicht im Griff.
Genau, genau.
Das haben wir jetzt gesehen und ähm wenn ihr jetzt hier noch nicht mal an uns ausliefert, ja,
dann und ne, sechs Monate äh irgendwie keine keine Ruhe in in irgendwie so eine Kleinstadt, muss man ja.
Für chinesische Verhältnisse ist Hongkong ja wirklich eine Kleinstadt noch. Wenn ihr da so eine kleinstädtig im Griff habt, dann äh müssen wir euch wohl sagen, wie.
Dieses Gesetz auszusehen hat und wie die Zukunft der inneren Sicherheit Hongkongs aussieht. Jetzt.
Das war, also was man über dieses Sicherheitsgesetz hört, ist wirklich enorm erstaunlich, weil der,
Es ist ein Gesetz mit sechsundsechzig Artikeln, das irgendwie eigentlich keinem bekannt war.
Bevor es verabschiedet wurde.
Ich verabschiede das nicht richtige Wort, glaube ich, aber.
Äh ähm,
bekannt gemacht wurde. Ja, also ähnlich ähnlich wie das, was in in Deutschland teilweise versucht wird, ne. Also wir haben ja auch einen Innenminister, der ähm
das zum Ziel hat, ja, um also der auch tatsächlich sagt, die Gesetze müssen kompliziert sein, damit sie keiner versteht und es keiner merkt,
Ja, damit die Leute nicht protestieren können. Das hat aber auch nicht nur der Innenminister in Deutschland macht das so, habe ich mich schon äh auch bei.
Damals noch Justizminister Heiko Maas drüber beschwert, dass eben der Gesetzgebungsprozess auf eine,
sich in die Intransparenz zurück,
zu ziehen versucht. Und äh das entspricht natürlich nicht der Demokratie. Das äh Gesetze verabschiedet werden über deren Inhalt nicht ausführlich äh diskutiert,
wurde und ein öffentliches Verständnis herrscht. So China ist aber keine Demokratie, deswegen ist das völlig in Ordnung, dass die sagen übrigens wir zaubern äh,
hier mal demnächst was aus dem Hut. Werdet da schon sehen. Werdet ihr schon sehen, was was wir uns da haben einfallen lassen. Und ähm.
Spezifisch, ähm versieht es vier Vergehen mit ähm.
Einer Höchststrafe von lebenslanger Haft.
Ja, jeden, jedem, jedem der Fälle, was wohlgemerkt nicht die schlimmste Strafe ist, die man in China äh bekommen kann. Also in der Volksrepublik ist die Todesstrafe durchaus mit durchaus verhängt und angewendet.
Ein moderates, ein moderates Gesetz.
Aber die Kapseln auf jeden Fall nicht mit mit fünfundzwanzig Jahren oder so, sondern nee, lebenslänglich. Und ja, da gibt's halt so vier, vier äh Kategorien, in denen man sich schuldig machen kann. Das eine ist äh Sezession, also ähm wird man das auf Deutsch sagen, ja.
Prinzipiell ein, ein, äh, Unabhängigkeit vom Mutterland. Wie nennt man das denn?
Ähm also wie nennt man das denn? Ja separat also separatismus Abnabelung.
Genau. Also generell ist also ähm.
Ich gucke mal, was der Service das deutsche Wort für Sezession. Sprich du mal weiter, ich suche.
Dann,
supressive Verhalten, ähm dann Terrorismus natürlich, das war auch schon verboten, ist jetzt aber nochmal ganz spezifisch explizit hier erwähnt äh und dann die Kollaboration mit fremden Mächten nochmal ganz spezifisch. Also das sind alles schon ziemlich,
allgemeine Begriffe. Ähm das wird dann nochmal ein bisschen konkreter in den Gesetzen. Wie gesagt, sechsundsechzig Artikel gesagt hat, aber ähm,
Aber in diesen vier Großen Kategorien und also das Gesetz wurde.
Ende Mai äh ja Ende Mai angekündigt, dass es sowas geben wird,
und ist dann am äh dreißigsten Juni in Kraft getreten, einen Tag bevor der vor der ähm vor dem Jahrestag der Hongkong äh Enstablishment auf der von der Hongkong äh,
bei speziellen Zone. Ähm im Augenblick, das ist jetzt halt drei Wochen her. Im Augenblick,
sind Leute sich noch nicht so klar, wie das jetzt wirklich in der Realität aussehen wird, sind aber natürlich schon am äh äh,
befürchten, dass bestimmte Szenarien halt eintreten werden, also spezifisch sind Leute sich halt nicht sicher, was jetzt halt als Subvention und was als Terrorismus zählt. Oder auch die Unterstützung oder Anleitanstiftung zu diesem, also ob jetzt die
das Aufhalten von Türen in der U-Bahn. Tourismus ist, weil damit natürlich schon die äh öffentliche Ordnung gestört wird.
Ist unglaublich, wie das ausgelegt werden wird und da haben die Leute im Augenblick Angst davor.
Laut äh Duden ist Sezession, die Absonderung oder die Verselbstständigung von Staatsteilen.
Hm. Von Staatsteil. Das Selbstständigen ist schön.
Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, also ich meine so eine machst du ja nicht.
Mal eben nebenbei, es sei denn, du bist ein Reichsbürger und hast herausgefunden, dass du in einer GmbH lebst und äh einfach deine eigene Währung einführen kannst, um auf,
gehöfft, äh Leute zu verarschen. Ähm.
Also Sezession, dass das äh das Absprengen, das die Verselbstständigung des Landes.
Ja genau, also so Brexit so quasi ist halt illegal jetzt das äh um das haben sie nochmal explizit gesagt, dass es halt nicht so eine Volksabstimmung geben kann und dann das reicht.
Und dann dann bist du weg.
Sondern halt auch generell und wohlgemerkt jetzt nicht, dass das der Akt als solches als solches illegal wäre, sondern auch jegliches.
Die Bestrebungen in diese Richtung, ja.
Subversion, dass die die Macht zu unterwandern, Terrorismus und Colusion mit mit äh externen Kräften. Ja oder.
Wie gesagt, alles sehr gummiartige, dass da kann man alles Mögliche reininterpretieren. Hier äh äh eher philosophische Konstrukte teilweise.
Und es ist nicht nur so, dass du damit ähm das Risiko hast ähm ein Leben lang in Haft,
zu landen, sondern also eine Auslegung, die ich lese, ist also was weiß ich, den den öffentlichen Nahverkehr zu beschädigen kann, Terrorismus sein,
Ne, wo jetzt die Frage ist, ne, muss der jetzt physischen Schaden nehmen oder wie du gerade schon sagtest, man hält die Tür länger auf, dass der Zug nicht weiter fahren kann.
Einfach so einen Generalstreik könnte da unter, je nachdem wie man es auslegt, da durchaus runterfallen.
Und? Diejenigen, die ähm schuldig sind, dürfen nicht mehr als öffentliche Vertreterinnen zur Wahl stehen.
Und äh auch Unternehmen können ähm irgendwie zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden.
Das sind beides sehr interessante Aspekte. Äh wir sollten mal kurz erwähnen, also ist vielleicht der höhere ein Begriff. Ähm
Eine der prominenteren Vertreter der Demokratiebewegung in Hongkong, aber auch irgendwie vor ein paar Monaten in Berlin und trifft sich mit äh mit mit äh Politikvertretern in Europa häufiger. Ähm,
er ist in der Demostiele Partei und die haben halt das ist halt wieder eine Auslegungssache, wie wir jetzt den Slogan Freedom vor Hong Kong.
Jetzt verstehen will, aber man kann das halt als bös gewillte, autoritäre Kraft schon so auslegen, als wäre das ein Aufruf nach Unabhängigkeit, was natürlich bedeutet. Und äh,
Insofern haben die sich jetzt halt doch aufgelöst. Ähm die die Partei war's halt nicht so richtig klar ist inwiefern inwiefern das alles noch, also vielleicht wissen die auch mehr als ich das. Äh gehe ich mal stark von aus. Ähm haben auf jeden Fall Grund zur Sorge,
das halt äh gilt genau diese, was du angesprochen hast, diese Formulierung dann halt, ähm der zumindest das das Spektrum begrenzen an, was man so politisch und demokratisch in Hongkong als Partei noch machen kann und fordern kann.
Vorsichtig man sein muss mit seinen Slogans.
Ich meine, okay muss ohnehin sehr vorsichtig sein, ne? Also der ist ein absolutes Gesicht, dieses Protest. Ähm ich glaube, inzwischen so in der ist dreiundzwanzig Jahre alt. Ähm.
So eine ähnliche Ikone wie Greta Thunberg äh habe ich den Eindruck, in in meiner Wahrnehmung.
Der war auch in zwotausendvierzehn schon bei den Protesten noch jünger, deutlich mehr baby-face, äh sehr, sehr im Vordergrund und hat auch genau dieses richtige ähm ja, nee, der der ist schon der, ja, der, der schafft die Leute. Äh,
auf seine Seite, weil er halt sehr, sehr, sehr authentisch.
Und dem also dem geht's natürlich also klar, ne, äh Subversion,
Könnte man ihm nachsagen. Sezessionsbestrebungen, kann man ihm nachsagen. Ähm Terrorismus mit einer mit einer großzügigen Auslegung.
Ja, je nachdem, wenn Generalstreik ist ja ein Unterbrechen, der hätte,
der öffentlichen Nahverkehrsmittel dann, ja? Also, dass er das kann man schon und dann, also, wenn man sich mit hier Außenministerien in Deutschland trifft und Europa und so, dann ist das, äh, vielleicht auch schon 'ne Kollaboration mit
fremden Kräften. Also wie gesagt, das ist dieses Ding, diese also ich habe mir jetzt wohl gemerkt, selber nicht diese sechsundsechzig Artikel durchgelesen. Ähm,
aber da haben Leute meines Verständnis nach im Augenblick halt Angst vor, dass das halt alles relativ interpretationsfreier, großen Interpretationsspielraum lässt, um halt,
alles äh.
Potentiell äh Leute, was Leute im Augenblick schon sich verhalten, wie sie sich seit Jahren verhalten, dass das dann halt direkt geahndet wird. Ähm des Weiteren äh regelt das Gesetz anscheinend auch halt das ähm Errichten und Finanzieren von,
äh vor Ort in Hongkong ähm spirituell.
Sicherheitskräften, also vor äh Polizeikräften, die dann eben außerhalb der der Hongkong ähm Sicherheitskräfte agieren,
vielleicht sollten wir an der Stelle nochmal kurz erwähnen, dass Hongkong ja in der Tat schon eine Füchse ähm Volksarmee äh Resistenz hat, also eine ähm,
Da gibt's äh paar Kasernen,
in Hongkong Island eine oder zwei und dann in noch ein paar ähm wort sind chinesische äh Militär.
Aber das sind kleine Dinger, ne? Weil es gab doch diese Bilder äh das war dann wahrscheinlich Ende zwanzig neunzehn. Nee, also in im hier äh.
Das war auch dann so im Oktober oder so, ja.
Aber da haben die, da haben ja diese ganzen Militärfahrzeuge noch in Shenzhen gestanden, oder? Oder äh also die standen quasi an der Grenze zu Hongkong, dann doch Unmengen an Militär hingestellt.
Ich habe das, ich habe das auch gesehen, dass aber nicht so klar, was da dann ähm im Endeffekt bei rauskam, aber unabhängig auch schon vor der Ampreday Revolution, auch schon direkt nach dem Handover, also seit neunzehnhundertsiebenundneunzig,
gibt es einfach eine stehende Karison von Volksrepublikarmee
Pipselation Armee, Volksbefreiungsarmee, äh der von China in Hongkong. Äh
gehen auch nicht irgendwie in die Kneipen da und haben auch nichts mit der Bevölkerung zu tun. Die bleiben einfach in ihrer Kaserne und spielen Volleyball den ganzen Tag. Machen halt Training, fahren ab und zu mit ihren Schnellbooten hin und her, aber sind prinzipiell einfach
nicht in der Gesellschaft drin, sondern haben einfach die kein äh dickere Sohn da, weil's halt ansonsten auch kein Militärpräsenz mehr gibt, seit die Briten weggezogen sind.
Ja äh also wenn du wenn du dieses Militär notfalls gegen die Bevölkerung einsetzen willst, dann solltest du die nicht mit denen in der Kneipe gehen lassen.
Zum Beispiel, dass er, ja.
Führt immer Zukunft.
Sprechen auch kein Kantonesisch wohlgemerkt, das äh ja, ja.
Oh Mann.
Aber das scheint jetzt halt mit diesem Secret Security-Gesetz halt nochmal ein nicht unbedingt militärisch klingende, sondern halt eher halt dieses.
Äh Dienstesicherung der.
So eine eigene Polizei, so lese ich das. Also sie wollen irgendwie eigene.
Polizei oder sowas.
Bundespolizei? Die und auch nicht an die sich nicht ähm nach der,
lokalen Juristikion richten muss. Das erinnert mich eigentlich so ein bisschen
kennt man in Deutschland nicht so wirklich, aber ähm wenn man sich irgendwie amerikanische Filme anschaut, dann gibt's doch immer diese äh Streitereien, ne, zwischen dem lokalen Polizi
und dem.
FBI.
FBI, ja? Und dann kommen FBI und sagt, na haha, das ist aber Federal und da sind wir für die Verfolgung zuständig und da hast du ähm.
Da hat das mit deiner Justice nichts mehr zu tun, was natürlich ähm eine enorm geschickte Angelegenheit ist.
Wenn du da jetzt auf einmal den Protest unter Hochverrat stellst und eine eigene äh Polizei und Strafverfolgungseinheit dafür so ist, die nicht wiederum an irgendwelche lokalen Gesetze gebunden ist, ne?
Genau und auch nicht an den Gesetzablauf im Sinne von, dass sie halt,
Richter vorgeführt wirst und Recht auf Anwalt hast und einen Telefonanruf und so, das war ja alles, das war ja bisher in Hongkong alles durchaus noch
aber dann ist viel zu als wäre dann halt sobald der, sobald er die um die bald zum Nationale Sicherheit geht, weil irgendwie im im Raum stehen, dann fällt das halt alles unter den Tisch und dann
dieses Gesetz insofern ja.
Und dieses dieses äh neue Security Office kann nämlich dann einfach auch offenbar entscheiden, oh dieser Fall ist aber von besonderer Schwere äh den schicken wir mal lieber nach äh Mail and China.
So, also nicht, dass hier wieder nicht, dass die Honkies das wieder nicht hinkriegen, ne. Das äh das wollen wir nicht, ne?
Und äh klar Hongkong muss sich da auch so ein bisschen drum kümmern, aber ähm wer das Ding das Ding wird unter der Beratung eines äh Advisors stehen, der von von kommt.
Der im Augenblick der Vorsitzende des äh Liazon Office ist, also ein.
Der chinesischen kommunistischen Partei und der Vorsitzende der Liazon. Also es gibt einen Lia-Song-Behörde für die Zusammenarbeit zwischen Hongkong und China, schon lange, also seit siebenundneunzig und das ist anscheinend dann auch unter deren
Aufgaben, das ist dann derselbe Mensch, der das macht, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Insofern, ja, prinzipiell,
wie gesagt, also Leute im Augenblick, wir haben spekulieren und noch nicht so richtig klar, also es hat jetzt noch keine von diesen äh Befürchtungen sind bisher noch nicht dokumentiert, eingetroffen, ähm aber das denken halt Leute, dass es wohl die Reise hingeht, dass halt
generell äh jetzt durch dieses Gesetz in Hongkong ähm dann auch wirklich.
Akut eingesetzt und wirksam werden. Ja und da hat natürlich niemand so richtig Lust drauf.
Und der entscheidende Faktor ist, dass also warum diese Befürchtungen steht, ist, dass die Interpretation,
eben nicht von irgendeinem äh Körper von Hongkong äh bestimmt wird, sondern von,
Ja, also ich glaube, dieser Vergleich ähm FBI Sheriff passt da besser, als ich zu Anfang dachte. Und ähm.
Das ist schon,
Also natürlich haben sie auch die Möglichkeiten zur Durchsetzung, also oder zur Verfolgung, ne, und Beobachtungen, das ist schon.
Wirklich ähm.
Ja, was wird das interessante? Inwiefern dann also einmal halt Strafverfolgung, ähm eigentlich sind die WM beredet haben, ist natürlich schon scheiße und wird alles nochmal eine ganze Spur härter, aber auch im Sinne im Vorfeld dann halt Überwachung und ähm und Zensur. Ähm.
Im Augenblick unklar, aber meine Einschätzung nach, wo die Leute eigentlich am meisten Angst vor haben, weil.
Wie niemand niemand, der in Hongkong wohnt, will ins chinesische Internet. Ja, also wenn das jetzt auf einmal so ist, dass man jetzt auch in,
Hongkong nicht mehr nach was googeln kann, was man will und das bei Wikipedia dann auch findet. Oder wenn er halt Posts, die man schreibt, gelöscht werden, einfach weil die halt automatisch irgendwelche Sachen getriggert haben oder weil
weil der Nachbar die angezeigt hat, ähm dass äh da haben die Leute wahrscheinlich am meisten Angst vor, weil die Leute in Hongkong das Internet schon,
Sehr gerne und genussvoll niesen, also das.
Also du glaubst, die du glaubst, dass das Internet hier noch noch also eine viel größere Bedeutung hat als äh als vielleicht zu Beginn angenommen, wenn wir jetzt hier über.
Ja, also ich meine, also gerade der Begriff der Version ist halt, ich meine, also.
Also Suggression, das ist ja, das ist schon was, was man online besser machen kann als als offline, finde ich oder zumindest in Hongkong vom Style her ist das auf jeden Fall ja, dass äh das wäre dann eher auf Message, Sports als irgendwie mit mit irgendwelchen Sprühkampagnen
Insofern haben da die Leute, denke ich, die die größte Befürchtung, dass halt die Firewall,
halt da nochmal ein bisschen nach äh bisschen nach Hong Kong reinkommt, aber was halt auch wieder Fragen aufwirft. Insofern, dass alles im Augenblick Spekulation, weil alles grade im Begriff äh implementiert zu werden,
Aber man sieht auch schon erste Reaktionen und Antworten, also spezifisch hat die einen York Times bereits irgendwie zwei Drittel oder ein Drittel ihres, äh die in Hongkong, also,
Hongkong ist ja wirklich so eine Metropole, von der aus dann ganz Asien irgendwie gemanagt wird, also zum Beispiel dann New York Times, haben dann halt ihr ihr Asienbüro, ihr Asienkorrespondenz in Hongkong sitzen ähm und die ziehen jetzt halt alle nach Südkorea oder,
Drittel davon oder zwei Drittel oder so. Ähm,
Man wird halt sehen, inwiefern das jetzt auch die äh zum Beispiel jetzt Banden, AJSBC oder ähm oder so halt auch so machen, das ist halt alles sehr.
Das war schon immer die Befristung, die Leute hatten seit neunzehnhundertsiebenundneunzig.
Jetzt die Frage, inwiefern das einfach nur die Einführung des Gesetzes reicht.
Dass Leute dann auch wirklich also Organisationen und Unternehmen dann auch wirklich sich entsprechend verhalten oder ob das halt erstmal alles so bleibt, wie es ist und dann halt.
Man abwarten wird, wie die wie die Durchsetzung äh Durchführung des Gesetzes ist.
Also ich denke, es gibt ja hier ein für mich sehr entscheidenden Faktor und das ist, dass hier mehr oder weniger ein,
ähm Gesetz kommt von einem,
Körper, über auf den, den die Leute nicht gewählt haben, die aber eben die, also die leben in einer Demokratie, mehr oder weniger,
Jetzt kommt ein Gesetz von einem Körper, den sie nicht wählen und auch nicht abwählen können. Und es kommt eine andere zusätzliche Polizei,
in ihre Stadt. Und auch wenn.
Vielen Menschen, viele Gesetze nicht gefallen, haben diese Gesetze ihre Legitimität dadurch, dass wir, zumindest theoretisch die Möglichkeit haben, auf diese Gesetze Einfluss zu nehmen,
Wenn sie sich in Deutschland eine Mehrheit findet, die, was weiß ich, sagt, ähm,
auf die Straße spucken, zwanzig Peitschenhiebe, ja,
wir können das hier diskutieren, wir können das entscheiden und dann wird es jeder falsch,
Wille des Volkes, ja? Und wenn uns die falschen Liebe zu wehtun, dann können wir das Gesetz auf einen sehr komplizierten Prozess eventuell dieses Gesetz wieder loswerden. Ähm,
Auch das ist äh sehr schwierig. Ne, und nicht häufig von Erfolg gesegnet, aber zumindest theoretisch ist es nachvollziehbar, dass wir diese Möglichkeit haben.
Was geht dir und mir so, aber ich möchte mal behaupten, dass Leute auch Angst haben, wenn die EU-Kommission dann bestimmte Peitschenhiebe vorschreibt und das dann, also ich meine, also ich weiß genau, was du.
Ne? Ganz ohne Frage, aber das ist, das ist der, der also ich will nur darauf hinaus, dass bei uns schon schwierig, deswegen will ich auch nochmal diesen Aspekt des Gesetzes betonen. Natürlich sind wir ähm in der Regel gegenüber äh gesetzlichen,
Legislistativen Bestrebungen mehr oder minder machtlos als Individuen, aber die bekommen ihre Legitimität daher, dass wir zumindest theoretisch eine Einflussmöglichkeit haben,
Und hier ist diese theoretische Einflussmöglichkeit auch nicht mehr gegeben. Und das, denke ich, ist hier der der entscheidende.
Delegitimierende Faktor dieses dieser gesamten Bestrebungen.
Absolut, also.
Absolut richtig, sehe ich genauso das Interessante ist wirklich, dass es halt auch erst seit neunzehnhundertsiebenundneunzig überhaupt der Fall war, weil halt davor als Grundkolonie war's trotzdem genau dasselbe. Ja, ich meine, also,
Das ist nur spezifisch die Generation, die halt zwischen neunzehnhundertsiebenundneunzig und zwanzig zwanzig halt erwachsen geworden und polizierte geworden ist.
Da gibt's doch auch so einen Begriff für diese, da gibt's doch so einen Begriff für diese Generation. Ich glaube Curst Generation, weil die weil die die ganzen äh Epidemien mitgenommen haben, saßen das Covid und irgendwie so in den.
Die die Finanzkrise und alles, ja, ja, ja, aber ja. Das äh, das kann sich im Nachhinein auch noch als drausstellen, dass er, das wird man sehen, aber der Punkt ist, dass, also, das ist jetzt nix Neues für Hongkong als sich, als solches,
dass er von jemandem regiert werden, wo sie keine Wahlrechte, keine, keine Vertretung erhalten im Parlament, in London haben, ja. Ähm.
Aber für diese Generation, die jetzt halt spezifisch, da dagegen ist, gegen demonstriert, äh die hatten halt dieses, dieses Wunder zumindest und insofern ähm ja.
Wird sich das schon nicht so schön anfühlen, wenn man das, ja, ja.
Wer da einmal an dem an der süßen Freiheit gerochen hat, der wird sich die nur sehr ungern wieder wegnehmen lassen.
Absolut und das also vom Selbstverständnis her ist es auch wirklich Teil des, dass das globalen westlich demokratischen,
der Kultur und man macht da mit und hat halt Meinungen und gibt die auch Kunde und so. Das ist halt in China wohnen ist was anderes, so wie ich das verstanden habe.
Und deswegen ist das alles, ja. Wie gesagt, man wird sehen, wie es kommt, aber das ist der Status im Augenblick. Ähm.
Wovor man weniger jetzt gelesen hat, wollte ich aber auch nochmal kurz erwähnen, es gab auch noch so, das kann man nur mal als Beispiel einfach so, was so jetzt potenziell einfach so auf uns auf Long Kong zukommen könnte. Ähm äh,
Anfang Juni gab's auch die Nationalhymne ähm Verordnung, die es auch in Hong Kong in Kraft getreten ist. Ähm und das ist halt mehr so, es gibt halt die.
Nationalhymne von China,
und die darf man jetzt auch per Gesetz nicht mehr vermurzen und irgendwie verharmlosen oder verändern oder lächerlichen oder verlächerlichen, man muss halt äh äh sehr ernsthaft stehen, wenn die gespielt wird,
oder nicht irgendwie lachen oder irgendwie
man darf die nicht verändern, man darf die nicht kommerziell benutzen und ebenfalls soll auch wiederum
äh entweder
was bedeuten könnte, dass es halt jeden Morgen gespielt wird irgendwie oder zu jeder Dreiviertelstunde oder so, auch das noch ein bisschen unklar, auch wegen Covid gerade. Ähm aber so in die Richtung, also halt so,
ironische Nationalismus mit all seiner Symbolik und all seinen Ritualen. Das kann halt auch passieren. Ja, ich meine, im besten Fall ist es halt so, so eine Geheimdienst
Polizei, die halt irgendwie deine E-Mails liest und die dann irgendwie Ärger macht und im schlimmsten Fall ist es halt wirklich jeden Morgen, der zu der Fahne salutieren und irgendwie Nationalhymne singen, also da da gibt's so ein ganzes Spektrum an potentiellen
schlichten Ausgängen, vor denen Leute Angst haben,
Ähm deswegen, das ist alles äh von der Hongkong Perspektive auf jeden Fall alles sehr, dass äh.
Das kann man sich besser ausdrücken. Ähm was wir auf jeden Fall noch kurz ansprechen müssen. Linus ist auch, wie das alles im größeren internationalen Rahmen.
Genau, weil wir also die ganze Zeit reden wir hier von wenigen Quadratkilometern, ja. Ähm.
Während China selber ja enorm ein enorm großes Land ist, ja und ähm dass,
denke, was wir auch noch ähm,
was noch sehr viel Entwicklungspotential hat, ne? Also das wird ja seit seit zwanzig, dreißig, vierzig Jahren, wird davon gesprochen, ja, wenn ne, wenn
die gelbe Gefahr erwacht oder ne, wenn jetzt, wenn jetzt China mal, wenn mal ganz China so aussieht wie Hongkong oder ganz China so aussieht wie Singapur oder Tokio, dann ähm,
spielen wir hier aber.
Das asiatische Jahrtausend hört das chinesische Jahrtausend, ja.
Aus dem Fischerdorf geworden, ne? Und die Bundesrepublik Deutschland ist zu einem Fischerdorf geworden. Ähm.
Das äh und China,
grade ich denke insbesondere äh jetzt in den letzten zehn, zwanzig Jahren, wird sich seines Potentials sehr, sehr.
Bewusst,
bereitet sich darauf vor und dieser Konflikt, den wir jetzt exemplarisch an Hongkong besprochen haben, wo es irgendwie mal so ein paar acht Millionen Leute auf ein paar Felsen,
betrifft, die aber schon der Nabel der Welt mehr oder weniger sind. Ähm der wird auch einen ganz anderen äh in ganz anderen Situationen noch ausgefochten. Wir haben jetzt Taiwan.
Vollständig außen vor gelassen. Ich denke, wir belassen es jetzt erst mal auch dabei.
Besser belassen, dass es auch schwer zu sagen, aber äh ein ein Thema, was äh.
Was auf jeden Fall auch nochmal weiter weiter aufkommen wird. Äh genauso wie halt ähm an der an der Grenze zu,
zu Nepal ähm ebenfalls halt ein ein Territorium von was als Creator zählt. Es gibt ja diese von Taiwan und
Macau in Hongkong dazu gehören und vielleicht dann auch noch Tibet und Kaschmir und so. Ähm je nachdem wie nationalistisch man ist oder bestimmte Inseln in in Nähe der Philippinen ähm,
Ja, in der Tat, also dann, also dass manches auch noch nicht mal mit international, also zum einen, also der.
Also China als Ökonomie und politische Macht ist halt schon, also im Aufschwung,
Ja und wenn das jetzt nicht alles komplett schief geht wegen irgendwelchen Coronaviren oder irgendwelchen internen Struggles, ähm weil die anderen,
möchte ja grad kollabieren mit Brexit oder oder was sind vor einigen Staaten grade stattfindet? Also ich meine net, das ist halt ähm das wird schon alles, wenn wenn die Weichen alle so makro makro strategisch und alle grade neu gestellt. Ähm.
Das kann man jetzt aber als eine sehr, sehr schwer äh über voraussagen, was ich mit internationalen Effekten oder Dingen meinte, ist eher so.
Wir haben jetzt davon geredet, was in Hong Kong los war,
Aber die Schauplätze, die Protestschauplätze waren jetzt nicht auf Hongkong beschränkt, also die waren ja nicht auf China beschränkt, sondern es war in der Tat so, dass auch international bestimmte Sachen einfach.
Also dass das die Proteste auch international, nämlich über äh spezifische Internetmedien ähm und generell die Medien halt halt darüber hinausgetragen wurden. Also spezifisch ist es so, es gab ja, wenn du dich an äh,
Boykott Blizzard erinnern kannst. Das war so ein Hashtag in wann war das? Auch das war alles so im Oktober,
Oktober letzten Jahres auf jeden Fall letzten Jahres zusammen mit den mit den ganzen ähm,
Protesten. Äh da war halt irgendwie, das war das ähm Spiel, kenne ich selber net, aber ist sowohl sehr beliebt und da hat jemand halt als gibt's wohl auch eine eine ähm professionelle Liga, äh Leute, die sich da
sich da gegeneinander messen. Und der Gewinner war halt aus Hongkong oder einer der,
Teilnehmer war aus Hongkong und hat dann halt Hong Kong äh Revolution of all times gesagt. Im,
und dann hat Lisa dem halt seinen Gewinn weggenommen und ihn halt rausgekickt, weil er halt irgendwie wie gegen die Blizzard,
Activision, Codes of Counterc verstoßen hat und da irgendwie, weißt du, halt da ähm seine Meinung geäußert hat, äh was dann aber nicht irgendwie immer zum mit dem Computerspiel zusammengepasst hat, das gab dann natürlich einen,
glücklicherweise einen Aufschrei auf Twitter mit dem Hashtag und so weiter. Ähm und da haben sich dann, haben sie, also das musste Blizzard dann auch zurücknehmen, aber.
Der Konflikt bleibt halt nicht in Hongkong, ja. Ähm erschreckender ist die Tatsache, dass es in Apple.
Meines Verständnisses nach, wenn man das iPhone,
Wenn man ein iPhone besitzt mit Apple, iOS iPhone ähm und das dann auf Hongkong äh die Sprachreisstellung Location of Funking einstellt, dann kann man halt auch nicht mehr das Taiwan-Emoji tippen,
Also du hast ja dein Keyboard und dem Keyboard gibt's so ein Emoji-Tab, das sind erstmal alle möglichen Smileys und dann alle möglichen Tiere, Hund und Katze und so weiter. Aber ganz hinten gibt's dann noch alle Fahnen, alle Flaggen von allen äh Nationen der Welt.
Machen bestimmte Leute bei Facebook und Twitter Regen Gebrauch von. Da gibt's auch eine Deutschlandfahne.
Genau. Gibt's auch eine liberika Fahne, die Leute dann als USA Fahne immer aus Versehen benutzen? Also ist ähnlich dumme Idee vom unicold Konsortium, dass überhaupt das also verstehe ich auch net, aber ja, das äh.
Dose Würmer, die sie nicht hätten aufmachen müssen.
Genau, genau, genau, alles sehr erstaunlich, aber.
Eine rote und eine schwarze Fahne. Insofern ist.
Das ist richtig, aber die sind auch nicht im selben, also ja, nicht in diesem National, ne, also ja. National fahren. Fahnen sind generell sehr schön, aber Nationalstaaten sind halt, ja, interpretationsoffener, das ist das Problem. Und äh der Punkt ist, dass man halt anscheinend jetzt,
denn normalerweise bin ich auf meinem iPhone Taiwan tippe, also TAIW WER ein, dann also Autovervollständigung sehe ich dann die Treiberanflagge
und ich habe die auch, wenn ich so durchscrolle, dann habe ich ganz rechts in den ganzen Zwischen dann, was immer tu Wallu und so weiter, halt aphobetisch sortiert, habe ich die Fahne. Das ist hier die Republik von China, ne, auf rot und blaues
richtig auf rotem Grund mit so einer Sonne drin äh habe ich da zur Auswahl. Und das ist anscheinend nicht der Fall, wenn dein iPhone aus Hongkong ist oder auf Hongkong Locations eingestellt ist.
Verständnis nach Erwartung nach als wenn er wohnst oder äh registriert bist, schauen wir überhaupt nicht, ne. Ähm aber.
Das sind halt so die Fragen von wie kriegt man das zusammen und wo endet,
die Hegemonie macht von China. Wir haben eine Sache noch nicht erwähnt. Lina ist zu dem ähm nationalen Sicherheitsgesetz und das ist die Tatsache, dass all diese Vergehen,
oder diese Kategorien, von denen wir geredet haben, von wegen Rezessionen und Subventionen und ähm.
Die der Terrorismus und die Kollaboration nicht etwa nur in Hongkong strafbar sind, sondern das ist egal wo du bist,
Wenn du das hier in Berlin machst, oder irgendjemand das irgendwo in,
Nicaragua oder Grönland oder Südafrika oder was auch immer macht, das ist ganz egal, das ist trotzdem noch illegal.
Und heißt auch eine Reise nach Hongkong kann dann zum Risiko werden.
Also spätestens die Reise nach Hongkong dann, ich meine.
Davon ausgehen, dass es im Augenblick nicht so einfach ist, ansonsten auf Chinesisches äh Recht durchzusetzen in anderen Teilen der Welt,
kann sich ändern in nächster Zeit. Das ist auf dem besten Weg dazu. Ähm ein Reise nach Hongkong ist auf jeden Fall was anderes dann, ne, wenn man jetzt hier irgendwie prominent die ganze Zeit irgendwie pfeift und äh und sowas fordert,
verstößt man offiziell gegen Richtlinien, die halt auch geahndet werden laut der der Text des Gesetzes ähm
Wenn man das irgendwie im Land wurde und Meinungsfreiheit existiert, wie Vereinigten Staaten oder Deutschland oder was immer ähm betreibt. Äh und das ist halt erschreckend. Vor allem, wenn's halt nach wie vor so ist, dass halt ein Internet gibt, ja, mit einem genauen Twitter und halt ein genauer Unicode,
das passt halt, das kollidiert halt, ja, also das ist halt die Frage. Betreibern so ganz spezifisch.
Also äh ich weiß, dass also diese ganzen Nationalstaaten, ich meine, ob,
man jetzt eine Fahne überhaupt erlaubt oder so, ne? Das ist ja noch eine Sache. Ähm es gibt auch zum Beispiel sehr große Unterschiede darin, wie sich dir Google Maps präsentiert, je nachdem.
Genau dasselbe.
Inseln da in den Philippinen und sowas. Ja, ja, das ist auch, je nachdem, welcher Benutzer da grade fragt, äh wird das auch also. Da geht's dann auch um die Schriftart und die Schriftgröße des Wortes Taiwan, weil Taiwan ist ja.
Der Name der Insel und das bestreitet niemand, dass da eine Insel ist. Die Taiwan heißt.
Typo geschrieben werden wie.
Taipay, dann dieselben Pfont und dieselbe Schrift oder was immer unterstrichen ist, genau wie Paking, Paking unterstrichen ist,
oder nicht, also ob Taipay dann typographisch als Hauptstadt zu erkennen ist oder nicht
Das sind genau die Sachen, wo es dann anscheinend in Software und Webseiten so Switches gibt, je nachdem, wer fragt, sieht dann halt, was er sehen will. Ähm insofern sieht das halt schon danach aus. Also, ich meine, diese Gesetzgebung.
Kann nicht funktionieren für alle Menschen auf äh aufm Internet,
Nichts, nicht gleichzeitig. Und insofern muss halt entweder zwei Internets geben oder man muss sich halt irgendwie einigen und es scheint deutlich einfacher zu sein, da Einfachheit, also Internetsplitt einzubauen ist.
Und und das, das ist doch, glaube ich, wenn es einfacher ist, den locationmäßig Internet-Split einzubauen,
Dann haben wir wieder auf einmal dieses Problem, dass dieses Internet, was uns eigentlich zusammenbringen wollte, irgendwie weiter auseinanderführt. Weil wir wir diskutieren einerseits über Filterblasen.
Der ähm,
in den sozialen Netzwerken, ne, aber wenn ich mein, was, wenn, wenn Google Maps uns in in Filterblasen über nationale Grenzen und unser Keyboard
in Filterblasen, über welche Faden äh es überhaupt an Nationalstaaten gibt, führt dann ist das,
glaube ich nicht der richtige Weg. Das ist ziemlich gefährlich.
Wird problematisch und das ist halt auch das wirklich.
Interessante an der Strategie, die China, die China gefahren hat, seit ein, zwei Jahrzehnten im Sinne von,
Sie haben ja die Firewall, ne? Wir hatten ja vorhin erwähnt, ähm aber wohlgemerkt gibt's in China halt auch äh Lok, also lokale Services, für alles, was man hier jetzt als Social,
Dienste, also eBay und Facebook und Twitter und.
Benutze die selber alle nicht so häufig, aber Instagram und prinzipiell alles und Amazon natürlich mehrere davon, alles was man,
westliche Internetdienste kennt und jeden Tag so benutzt in seiner Konsumer Online äh Welt. Ähm dafür gibt's ein chinesisches Pendant in chinesischer Sprache, in chinesischem,
Hoheitsgebiet administriert.
Mit chinesischen Umsätzen. Also.
Und auch wohlgemerkt meistens mit Regierungsbeteiligung an den Location, an den anderen Konzernen jetzt oder Alibaba oder was, das sind alles keine absolut unabhängigen ähm Organisationen, aber der Punkt ist, die Chinesen, die Chinesen,
Bevölkerung als solches hat halt sich selber ihr eigenes Internet gebaut. Das ist noch derselbe, IPV vier Basic und Hierarchie ist es schon noch auf derselben Ebene, aber prinzipiell sind sie halt nicht gebunden,
die westlichen Dienste irgendwie zu. Ähm sie sich zu sehr darauf zu verlassen.
Du meinst äh du meinst äh Alibaba ist nicht auf AWS gehostet.
Absolut nicht. Eher andersrum. Eher andersrum. Aber deswegen, das wird schon, das also das sieht schon so aus, also es kann jetzt also
Das sind absolut konträre sich gegenüberstehende äh Weltanschiedansichten und halt Fakten lagen
also übertimer. Wahrscheinlich so schnell keine keine Einigung erreichen kann, einfach nur im Diskurs und es scheint einfacher zu sein, dann halte einfach so einen Split. Die Firewall halt noch ein bisschen weiter zuzuziehen und da einfach so einen Split durchzumachen.
Und das ist tatsächlich das, was wir eigentlich einschränken, was wir eigentlich verhindern wollen, ne? Ich meine, dass du in jedem Land deine eigene Weltanschauung, deine eigenen Bücher hast.
Das war früher einmal, das das ist halt auch das, also das ist am Ende Devide at Impara.
Dummerweise, wenn du sagst, wir wollen alle auf das Gleiche blicken und alle alles allen verfügbar machen, dann versuchen natürlich, Großmächte das zu definieren, was da steht, ne? Sei es.
Aus und Deutungshoheit. Kampf um die Deutung zu.
Deutungsdeutungswort zu gewinnen. Und dann ist natürlich auch wieder klar zu sagen, naja, wenn alle um die Deutungswhite kämpfen, hey komm, dann lass uns doch einfach,
eine kleine Great Firewall machen für ein paar Milliarden und dafür sorgen, dass wir wenigstens bei uns die Deutungshoheit haben, dann sollen die anderen doch was anderes glauben, wo die Grenze ist. Und.
Tanzen auch alle Leute glücklich, aber also beziehungsweise glücklich miteinander, weil sie dann halt die die andere Deutung nicht mehr sehen müssen, aber äh gibt dann halt auch Spielraum, den man den eigentlich nicht haben will.
Weißt du, wer die einzigen sind, die sich von den Separatisten auf der Nase rumtanzen lassen? Europa, hier von den Briten, ja?
Europa. Das ist absolut richtig. Rezession ist äh absolut legal und äh auch wenn's ein bisschen chaotisch war, dann doch halbwegs demokratisch verlaufen, ja.
Aber es wäre besser für Großbritannien gewesen.
Ja, ja.
Es gab natürlich dann, also es gibt natürlich auch noch solche Sachen wie hier äh Hongkong, Map dot life. Ne, das war diese im Prinzip diese von Hong Kong, die,
ja, dadurch, ich meine, wenn das wenn die gesamte Disco irgendwie auf Central stattfindet und Central kannste,
Ja okay, kannst du an einem Tag drum rumlaufen? Nee, dafür ist.
Ist halt schon sehr steil, aber aber prinzipiell also ist schon, also ist schon alles.
An dem Süden von Central.
Also prinzipiell das sind halt so, ja aber das sind halt das ist ja nicht mehr Central, also Hongkong Island ist prinzipiell nur dieser Berg
und dann wo der Berg anfängt bis zum Ufer, das sind halt nur so fünfhundert, achthundert Meter oder vielleicht zwei Kilometer an bestimmten Stellen, die da super dicht besiedelt sind oder zumindest voller riesiger Banking Hochhäuser stehen, aber da kann man schon.
Da kannst du gemütlich durchlaufen, ja. Und da hat sich das alles konzentriert und dann haben sie mit Hongkong Map.
Ja, das war's. Das war schon Hongkong weit, aber Prinzbill, also Hongkong Mac
Map dort live, war sowohl ein eine Website, also eine mobile Website als auch eine mobile App für iOS und ich glaube auch für ähm Google Play Store, ähm die halt, wo halt äh benutze, Couchsourcing
äh basiert sagen konnten, wo stehen die Polizei beziehungsweise wie viel Polizei ist hier? Ist ja da, wo sind die Wasserwerfer? Ja, es sind ja nur zwei oder drei Wasserwerfer, die sie überhaupt hatten und wie viel
Polizeiautos sind wo und prinzipiell ein taktische so so ein Tactical ähm,
äh die Website war super hilfreich, die haben viele Leute benutzt, also halt auf der taktische oder auch einfach nur ums zu vermeiden, ne, von wegen ich will mit meiner Familie erst shoppen gehen, wo gehe ich nicht hin. Es hat einfach gezeigt,
wo es hier gerade irgendwie Tränengaseinsatz und so. Ähm aber es gab halt auch eine Mobile App und die Mobile App hat Apple dann vorm App Store entfernt, weil die halt
nicht mit denen, also die offizielle Begründung war dann, glaube ich, irgendwie, dass es halt irgendwie weiß nicht, Ärger gibt,
mit der Polizei, also das ist halt irgendwie halt so Unruhe und äh Stiftung oder so führen oder beitragen würde. Äh man kann davon ausgehen, dass das halt auf Bestrebungen der Regierung gemacht wurde. Ähm
aber.
Das ist halt auch nichts, ne, wenn da wenn da ein Konzern, der ja wohlgemerkt auch mehr eine sehr, sehr komplexe Beziehung zur sowohl als auch Hongkong als auch zur Volksrepublik als Ganzes hat. Ähm,
Wenn die dann halt so so einfachen Switch ein aus dann halt so so viel Macht haben und den dann halt die dann halt auch einfach so ausüben können. Äh,
Ist ja auch nicht so einfach.
Wir haben schon vor der Aufzeichnung uns überlegt, dass es wahrscheinlich bei dieser Sendung.
Nochmal Zeit wird für die LNP-Melodie in Moll. Ähm.
Ich möchte erstmal danken, weil das äh diese Sendung ist, äh genau so geworden, wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe und besser, weil wir hoffentlich ein bisschen ein äh.
Ja, einen weiteren Blick auf diese Geschehnisse ähm und auf die Situation in Hongkong geben konnten. Dank der vielen Zeit, die du dort verbracht hast. Ich hoffe,
Dass wir beide irgendwann auch nochmal nach Hong Kong können.
Hoffe ich doch sehr, dass äh nach wie vor einer meiner Lieblingsstädte.
Und ähm dass wir dort auch in Zukunft noch ähm sehr viel Freiheit genießen können. Ich denke, dass dieser Freiheitskampf.
Die Menschen dort geführt haben und zwar wohlgemerkt zum Erhalt ihrer Freiheit nicht zum Erkämpfen einer Freiheit oder sonstigen. Äh.
Sehr, sehr beeindruckend ist, auf, auf, auf so vielen Ebenen, insbesondere, wie du sagst, ja, das das sind jetzt keine erfahrenen äh.
Berufswirulanten.
Oder sonst was, ne? Die haben kaum die Zeit, ne? Das ist eine, auch eine sehr getriebene Stadt, also man sieht da selten, also ich habe den Eindruck, dass alle Leute sich da schon relativ zügig bewegen und,
von der einen Sache zur anderen hetzen und so, ne? Und wenn die sich so viel Zeit in ihrem Leben nehmen und sich in Millionen.
Zusammentun, um bisschen freier zu verteidigen, was sie jetzt auch nicht in übertriebenem Maße ausgenutzt haben, ähm dann ist das beispielhaft für viele und dann,
Können wir nur hoffen, dass wir ähm solche Kämpfe nicht führen müssen.
Bleibt zu hoffen. Danke Lenas.
Ich danke dir für diese Zeit und ich äh würde mich freuen von
von unseren Hörerinnen, ihr seid damit angesprochen ein bisschen Feedback zu bekommen, ich denke das war jetzt sowohl was die Länge angeht als auch was das Format angeht, was äh was ganz anderes,
im Logbuch. Ähm mir war das aber eine Herzensangelegenheit. Wie gesagt, ich halte ich schwanke zwischen Tokio und Hongkong,
aber ich tendiere zu Hong Kong als wirklich äh schönste Stadt, coolste Stadt dieses Planeten, die ich bisher gesehen habe und ähm,
Hoffe, dass sie uns erhalten bleibt.
Ja. Danke.